THERE WERE ELIMINATING
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND
HEARING SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO LEGISLATIVE PROCESS TO ALLOW
FOR PUBLIC ACCESS AND WE ARE
COMMITTED MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
TO THE HEARING ROOM TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE- THE IS THE
PARTISAN NUMBERS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE THREE. THE ACCESS CODE IS
SEVEN ZERO FIVE SIX NINE ZERO
NINE FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCES DIM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE. AND ARE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. I CALLED THIS MEETING
TO ORDER AND ESTABLISH A
QUORUM- COULD SOME PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN HERE AND HERE
BATES. BATES HERE DALLI DALLI
HERE GONZALEZ SKINNER YOUR
SKINNER HERE STERN. BURKE OWSKI
OKAY AND I ASSUME THAT- SUMER
HOLDEN IS ON HIS WAY. IT'S ON
BUT THAT'S NOT CONSENT OKAY
FANTASTIC. THANK. OKAY- THAT'S
RIGHT THAT'S RIGHT SO SOMEWHERE
FRIEDMAN. THEN ON OUR WAY OKAY
WHILE WE WAIT FOR HER WILL KEEP
TALKING ABOUT- THE PROCESS SO
WHEN WE MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT OPPOSITION PRESSES
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU TO A LINE NUMBER.
THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR
THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
AND YOU DID AND YOU ARE NOW
READY TO ADDRESS. THE COMMITTEE
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY INTO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
PLEASE PLEASE ME THE DEVICE
YOU'RE WATCHING HEARING ON
PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE IT'S IMPORTANT WE
HEAR FROM YOU WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. WE'RE GONNA
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL IS DISRUPTED MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THE CONNECTIONS
NEEDED. WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS
BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HEARING PROCESS CONDUCTED
HEARINGS IN IS CLOSEST TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIME FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
OR TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL. AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD
WE HAVE A BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. THREE THE BILLS ARE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. SO IN
ORDER TO GET THIRTIES COUNTER
NOT A LOT OF HEARING TIME
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WILL BE
LIMITED TO TEN MINUTES EACH
WITH EACH INCLUDES THREE
MINUTES FOR. LEAD WITNESS
TESTIMONY IN THE REMAINDER OF
THE TIME FOR ADDITIONAL CALLERS
AND SUPPORT OPPOSITION. SO WE
HAVE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM-
LET'S BEFORE YOUR FIRST BILL
LET'S HAVE OUR MEMBERS VOTE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR THE ITEMS
ON CONSENT ITEMS ONE. SEVEN AND
EIGHT. WE HAVE A MOTION TO FOR
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. MOVED BY
OUR VICE CHAIR- CENTER BASE THE
SENATE BATES WE HAVE A MOTION
AGAINST MOVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CONSULT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEMS ONE SEVEN AND
EIGHT ALLEN HI I BATES BATES
AYE DALLI DALLI AYE GONZALEZ
SKINNER. AYE SKINNER AYE STERN
Y. CASKEY. OKAY CONSENT ORDER
HAS PASSED BUT- WE WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE MEMBERS
OUT ON WE SEE WE WELCOME YOU
HERE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN
YOU'RE HERE TO PRESENT AB SIX
FIVE TWO AND YOU MAY PROCEED
WHEN READY THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I WANT TO
FIRST THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF
FOR THIS FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
BILL I WILL ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ON PAGE
NINE OF THE ANALYSIS. SB SIX
FIFTY TWO WOULD PROHIBIT THE
INCLUSION OF P. FAST CHEMICALS
AND A WIDE RANGE OF JUVENILE
PRODUCTS. SUCH AS SLEEP MATS
NURSING PILLOWS CAR SEATS AND
CRIBS MATTRESSES. THESE THESE
CHEMICALS ARE OFTEN USED- WITH
THE CLAIM THAT THEY MAKE
PRODUCTS MORE STAIN RESISTANT
ALTHOUGH THAT CLAIM IS FAIRLY
DUBIOUS. AND YOU KNOW AS A MOM
WHEN I BUY A MATTRESS PAD FOR
MY DAUGHTER IN CALIFORNIA OR
ANY PRODUCT THAT'S GONNA BE
TOUCHING MY DAUGHTER'S SKIN AS
A BABY. I ASSUME THAT IT'S
COMPLETELY SAFE AND THAT
ANYTHING THAT'S UNNECESSARY
THAT HAS ANY CHANCE OF CAUSING
HER HARM WOULDN'T BE THERE BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S NOT THE
CASE IN CALIFORNIA. BUT WE KNOW
THAT P. FAST CHEMICALS HAVE
BEEN SHOWN AND PROVEN TO HAVE
AN ADVERSE IMPACT ON HUMAN
HEALTH AND THAT THEY ARE
ABSORBED THROUGH THE SKIN AND
CERTAINLY THROUGH THE MOUTH AND
ANYONE IS NOT A CHILD KNOWS
THAT EVERYTHING GOES IN THEIR
MOUTH- EVENTUALLY. IMPACTS TO
ADULTS ALBUM HAVE BEEN SHOWN TO
INCLUDE LIVER DAMAGE INCREASE
RISK OF THYROID DISEASE AND
DECREASED ANTIBODY RESPONSE TO
VACCINES HEALTH IMPACTS THE
CHILDREN INCLUDE SUPPRESSED
IMMUNE SYSTEMS. IMPAIR KIDNEY
FUNCTION AND DELAYED ONSET OF
MENSTRUATION. A RESEARCH INTO
THE STUDIES INDICATE THAT
HEALTH EFFECTS ARE OCCURRING AT
COMMON EXPOSURE LEVELS IN THE
GENERAL POPULATION AND THESE
CHEMICALS. ARE NOW FOUND TO BE
PRESENT IN HUMAN BLOOD. DID HE
A C. AS THE P. FAST HORRIBLE
HEALTH AND THE NEEDS REMOVE
FROM CERTAIN. SUCH AS CARPET.
HOW MANY JUVENILE PRODUCTS AS
DEFINED BY THE BILL CONTAINED
FEW FAST. WHICH CAN MIGRATE
INTO- CHILDREN THROUGH SKIN
ABSORPTION AND THROOP DUSTS
THAT THAT THAT COULD BE COMING
OFF OF THESE PRODUCTS. AND
THESE CHEMICALS ARE CERTAINLY
NOT ESSENTIAL TO THESE PRODUCTS
AND I WOULD MUCH RATHER HAVE A
STAIN ON A BED SHEET OR
INCLUDING THAT HAVE A OF
CHEMICAL THAT'S HARMFUL IN MY
DAUGHTER'S BLOOD STREAM AND- I
JUST THINK IF PARENTS IN
CALIFORNIA NEW. ABOUT THESE
CHEMICALS IN THESE PRODUCTS THE
REALLY BE OUTRAGE THAT WE ALLOW
THIS TO HAPPEN IT'S NOT WHAT
THEY EXPECT FROM CALIFORNIA
PRODUCTS. HOW WE WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND WE'VE NARROWED
WHAT IS CAN DISCONCERTED UNDER
THE BILL AS A JUVENILE PRODUCT
TO EXCLUDE CHILDREN ELECTRONICS
MEDICAL DEVICES. AND INTERNAL
COMPONENTS OF CHILDREN'S
PRODUCTS AND ADULT MATTRESSES.
THESE AMENDMENTS REMOVE THE
OPPOSITION OF THE INTERNATIONAL
SLEEP PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION AND
ADVANCED MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION. A RESTRICTION ON
THE SALE OF CERTAIN PRODUCTS
CONTAINING P. FAST IS THE ONLY
WAY TO ENSURE THAT EVERY
CALIFORNIA'S ACCESS. TO
PRODUCTS THAT ARE TRULY SAFE.
AND I DON'T PRESENT A HEALTH
RISK JUST FROM THEIR EXISTENCE
IN THE HOME. AB SIX FIFTY TWO
IS SUPPORTED BY THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP OF
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS CAL CALIFORNIA. SMU
A CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
CLEAN WATER ACTION ORANGE
COUNTY WATER DISTRICT. AND SAN
FRANCISCO DEPARTMENT OF THE
ENVIRONMENT AND MAY I SAY AS
SOMEONE WHO SAT ON A WATER
BOARD FOR FIVE YEARS. HE
FASTENED THE WATER SUPPLY IS AN
EMERGING CONTAMINANT AND A HUGE
CONCERN FOR WATER AGENCIES WHO
KNOW THAT THEY'RE GONNA BE ON
THE HOOK FOR REMOVING THESE-
THIS THE SUBSTANCE OUT OF THE
WATER EVENTUALLY BECAUSE WE'RE
ALL DRINKING THIS EVERY SINGLE
DAY. THIS IS THE LOW HANGING
FRUIT WHEN IT COMES TO REMOVING
P. FAST CONTAMINATION. THAT IS
EXPOSING OUR MOST VULNERABLE
MEMBERS. I APPRECIATE YOUR
THOUGHTFUL CONSIDERATION AND I
WOULD URGE AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT I
BELIEVE THAT- WE'VE GOT. TO
ALLOW YOU TO SPEAK FIRST FROM A
FROM A WORKING GROUP IN SUPPORT
HI I'M BILL ALLEY- GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS DIRECTOR IN CALIFORNIA
FOR THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING
GROUP AND WE'RE SPONSORING THE
BILL I WANT TO INTRODUCE FIRST
DAVE ANDREWS PHD OF OUR STAFF
HE'S GOING TO GIVE US A BRIEF-
TESTIMONY ON THE SCIENCE OF P.
FAST AND WHY THE CONCERN. DAVE
THANK YOU AND I HOPE EVERYONE
CAN HEAR ME- THANK YOU JOHN
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN FOR
INTRODUCED IN THAT. THE BILL.
MY NAME'S DAVID ANDERS I HAVE A
PHD IN CHEMISTRY AND I'M A
SENIOR SCIENTIST FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP. I
HAVE PUBLISHED NUMEROUS REPORTS
AND WORKED ON OUR P. THOUGHT
CONTAMINATION THAT. ALSO CO
AUTHORED FIVE PEER REVIEWED
PUBLICATION ON TEACH US THE
CURRENT THAN HELP IT. FIFTY
THOUSAND IN THE NATION AS THE
NATIONAL PUBLIC ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH EMERGENCY AND URGENT
ACTION IS NEEDED TO REDUCE AND
ELIMINATE EXPOSURE AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE. RECENT STUDIES
INDICATE THAT HUMANS BOTH
ADULTS AND CHILDREN ARE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO. THE HEART
COMPUBOX EXPOSURE. EXPOSURE
LEVELS COMMON ALREADY IN THE
GENERAL POPULATION ARE
IMPACTING HEALTH. IN CHILDREN
ARE PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE TO
PEOPLE IT'S INTACT ESPECIALLY
TO THE IMMUNE SYSTEM INCLUDING
REDUCING THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
VACCINES. AND HARM DURING
CRITICAL PERIODS OF DEVELOPMENT.
FOR THAT DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL SAFER
CONSUMER PRODUCTS PROGRAM HAS
ALREADY CONFIRMED THAT P. FIVE
OUR THREAT TO HELL. THEY HAVE
ALSO DETERMINED THAT P. FIVE
SHOULD BE REGULATED AS AN
ENTIRE CLASS NOT JUST CHEMICAL
BY CHEMICAL THIS REALLY
INCLUDES THE FLOOR POMMEL
MURDERS THE SHORT TERM
REPLACEMENT CHEMICALS AND THERE
ARE HUNDREDS OR THOUSANDS OF
THESE P. FIVE'S COMPOUND. IT IS
BECAUSE OF THE URGENT HEALTH
PRIORITY OF PROTECTING CHILDREN
THAT HE W. AS PROUD TO SPONSOR
EIGHTY SIX FIFTY TWO. THAT'LL
LEMONADE THIS UNNECESSARY AND
POTENTIALLY HARMFUL USE OF
PEOPLE AND CHILDREN'S PRODUCTS.
THESE PRODUCTS LEAD TO EXPOSURE
THROUGH CONTACT WITH THE SKIN
AND INHALATION OF DUST. AND
EITHER CLICK CHEMICAL THE
CULTURE EVER CHEMICAL THEY DO
NOT BREAK APART IN THE
ENVIRONMENT AND THEY CAN BUILD
UP IN PEOPLE. THESE ARE NOT
CHEMICALS THAT BELONG IN OUR
CHILDREN. MANY PEOPLE IT'S
ACCUMULATING BLOOD AND THESE
CHEMICALS ARE DETECTED IN
NEARLY EVERY SINGLE PERSON IN
THE COUNTRY. INCLUDING INTENT.
I'VE SEEN EIGHTY SIX FIFTY TWO
IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD IN
REDUCING THIS REALLY
UNNECESSARY EXPOSURE. AND WHAT
THE CALIFORNIA IN THE LEAD OF
PROTECTING OUR CHILDREN. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK
YOU CAN I BILL ELLIOTT
ENVIRONMENT WORKING GROUP WILL
BE BRIEF WE WISH THE SAFER
CONSUMER PRODUCTS PROGRAM AT
DTS HE COULD HAVE A LIST AND
BUT AND THEY WILL MAYBE SOME
DAY BUT AS THE LEGISLATURE IS
FINDING OUT THAT PROCESS IS
GOING REALLY REALLY SLOWLY AND
WE LIKE THE STAFF THERE IT'S A
GOOD PROGRAM BUT SOMETIMES THE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO STEP IN
WHEN THERE'S A MORE URGENT
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE AS THERE IS
IN THIS CASE NATIONALLY WE'RE
LOOKING AT TRYING TO HAVE
ESSENTIAL USES ONLY OF THIS
CHEMICAL FOR NOW. AND
NONESSENTIAL USES SUCH AS
CODING A CHILD'S A NURSING
PILLOW OR CAR SEAT ELIMINATED-
I WANT TO SAY THIS IS ONE OF
THE BEST WORKING RELATIONSHIPS
I'VE EVER HAD WITH THE
OPPOSITION WE'VE WAITED THROUGH
A LOT OF TOUGH ISSUES WE'RE
DOWN TO SOME TECHNICAL LANGUAGE
ON THE DEFINITION IN THE
THRESHOLD THAT I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO COME TO AGREEMENT ON
REALLY SOON WE COULDN'T QUITE
GET THERE BY TODAY BUT WE WELL
I'M PRETTY SURE SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. AND I REMAIN
IN THE ROOM FOR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU PART OF THE PHONE
LINES. SHE IF ANYONE. WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY SEEM BECAUSE I
DON'T SEE ONE IN PERSON AND
EITHER THE ROOMS. SOAP
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD GO TO
THE PHONE LINES AND ACCEPTEZ
COMING UP FOLKS WANT TO ADD ON
IN SUPPORT. FOR A BI. SIX FIFTY
TWO. MODERN YOU THERE. YES I AM
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY TWO. THE
NEW WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIX FIFTY TWO
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME LITTLE FIRST MOVED TO LINE
EIGHTY GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT
WHILE WE OPEN YOUR LINE PLEASE.
K. LINE AT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE KEEP HER ID
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL CALLING IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. BY NINETY. I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD
MORNING MARK FENSTER MAKER ON
BEHALF OF JUSTICE WE TO SUPPORT
THE BILL THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO
LINE. EIGHTY EIGHT. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS JIM WHEN BURKE-
BEHALF OF A FRIEND COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE SIXTY
EIGHT. GOOD MORNING CLINTON THE
BACK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION ADVOCACY
IN SUPPORT. NINE SEVENTY. HELLO
MY NAME IS ANDREA EVAN TURNER
WITH CLEAN WATER ACTION AND
I'VE BEEN ASKED TO LEAD THE
LIST OF SUPPORTERS- NEED
SUPPORTERS TO SAVE THE-
COMMITTEE TIME. SO WITH YOUR
INDULGENCE- THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS SUPPORT THIS BILL
ALLIANCE OF NURSES FOR HELP THE
ENVIRONMENT. AMERICAN ACADEMY
OF PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA
AMERICAN COLLEGE ABOUT STRESS
OBSTETRICIANS AND GYNECOLOGISTS
DISTRICT- NINE BAY AREA
POLLUTION PREVENTION GROUP.
BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP
OUNCIL. CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION POWER BERG CENTER
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH CENTER
TO PUT SAFETY THE CENTER FOR
PUBLIC ENVIRONMENTAL OVERSIGHT.
CHILDREN NOW CLEAN WATER ACTION
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA. BACKS FAMILIES
ADVOCATING FOR CHEMICAL AND
TOXIN SAFETY FRANCE COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA
WAS ANGELES COUNTY SANITATION
DISTRICT. NATIONAL STEWARDSHIP
ACTION COUNCIL ORANGE COUNTY
WATER DISTRICT PHYSICIANS FOR
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA CHAPTER. THE
REGIONAL WATER AUTHORITY SAN
FRANCISCO BAY PHYSICIANS FOR
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY STATE PER
STATE SAN FRANCISCO DEPARTMENT
OF THE ENVIRONMENT SANTA CLARA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT AND
SEVENTH GENERATION. ADVISORS
THANK YOU. NINE NINE ONE. YES
FINDING WAS ALREADY SAID-
REFERENCE PREVENTION PARTNERS
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BLIND. EIGHTY SIX. THE MORNING
CARE NUMBERS CHRISTOLOGY DOCKED
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO AND
NATIONAL STEWARDSHIP ACTION
COUNCIL IMPROPERLY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. TO VOICE YOUR
SUPPORT AND PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE KNOWN AND YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU I LET'S GO TO
OPPOSITION WITNESSES- WE HAVE
DON KHAKI FROM C. N. TA AND
ALSO TIM CHAU STICK FROM THE
ACC. ALWAYS ALREADY DONE GOOD
MORNING. TEN GOVERNOR ALEX.
THANK YOU- MEDICARE MEMBERS BUT
CONSISTENT WITH THE MERICAN
CHEMISTRY COUNCIL THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNIT TO TESTIFY
TODAY WHY WE CURRENTLY HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
I DO WANT TO THANK YOU AUTHORED
AND SPONSORED OR THE ONGOING
DIALOGUE IN. WORKING WITH OUR
COALITION INCLUDES SEVERAL
AMENDMENTS SINCE THE BILL WAS
INTRODUCED. AMENDED MATCHING
THOSE US I WON'T NOT REITERATE-
THE- IMPROVEMENTS IN OUR VIEW
THE BILL- THUS FAR- AND
REFLECTED IN THE ANNOUNCES ONE
REMAINING ISSUE- OF THE SENATE
IS THE DEFINITION OF
INTENTIONALLY ADDED. SUBSTANCES
WE HAVE BEEN IN DISCUSSION.
ALUALU YOU AS TO WHETHER THIS
DEFINITION COULD BE BETTER
ALIGNED WITH OTHER. STATUTES
THAT HAVE BEEN ENACTED. IN THE
CHEMICAL BAY. OUT WE ANOTHER
MEMBERS OF THE ARE CURRENTLY
REVIEW FROM LANGUAGE SPOKEN
LAST FEW DAYS. BASED ON A CLEAN
PRODUCT INGREDIENT DISCLOSURE
BILL AN ACT A FEW YEARS AGO. WE
ARE STILL AWAITING FEEDBACK
FROM ALL OF OUR INDUSTRY A
COALITION STAKEHOLDERS. BY THIS
LANGUAGE IS CERTAINLY- TRENDING
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION IN MY
VIEW AND I AM VERY OPTIMISTIC
ABOUT RECEIVING FINAL FEEDBACK.
IN THE COMING DAYS. I DO WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE AGAIN THE
WILLINGNESS THE AUTHOR IN THE
PROPONENTS TO ENGAGE IN A
CONSTRUCTIVE DIALOGUE. I ALSO
WANT TO THANK- YOU CENTER ALLEN
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR YOUR
ENGAGEMENT. WE ARE COMMITTED.
TO RESOLVING THIS ISSUE AS THE
BILL MOVES TO THE SENATE. I
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY.
THE TERM HOW WILL GO TO DANTE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
DON KHAKI WITH THE CUTE CAT CAN
AFFECT IT ABOUT HALF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION. WHICH
YOU CURRENTLY HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON AB
SIX FIVE ZERO FIVE THAT SAT J.
IN LINE WITH YOUR SHOP COMMENTS
SINCERELY APPRECIATE THE
SIGNIFICANTLY HELPFUL
AMENDMENTS TAKEN UP ALREADY
AUTHOR IN THE- OR THE SCOPE OF
WHAT WOULD CONSTITUTE A
JUVENILE PRODUCT. WE ALSO
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS REGARDING YOUR
IRANIAN ISSUE AT THE
MANUFACTURING COMMUNITY HAS NOT
THE BILL NAMELY THE DEFINITION
INTENSELY ADDED NOT
WITHSTANDING OUR CURRENT
CONDITION WE BELIEVE THE
CONVERSATION HOUSE REFINEMENTS
UNDER DISCUSSION ABOUT
LEGISLATURE DIONYSIAN
UNINTENTIONALLY ADDED ARE
INDEED HAD ADDED A MORE
WORKABLE DIRECTION IN MIND THE
CURRENT INTENTIONALLY OUT OF
PROVISIONS IN THE STATUTE
TODAY. FURTHER DISCLOSURE OF
PROHIBITED SUBSTANCES
LEGISLATION TO THAT END THE NPA
IS ALSO WORKING WITH A NUMBER
OF COMPANIES THAT ARE HOPEFUL
THAT WITH SOME REQUIREMENTS TO
THE INTENTIONALLY ADDED
DEFINITION CURRENTLY IN THE
BILL ALONG THE LINES OF WHAT
CURRENT DISCUSSIONS ARE
HAPPENING BUT WE ARE HOPEFUL
THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO REMOVE
OPPOSITION TO AB SIX FIVE TWO
IN THE COMING DAYS. I IN THE
MEANTIME IT WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN HER
STOP AND- SEARCH FOR THEIR
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH THAT
AND THE MANUFACTURING COMMUNITY
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
STRATEGIST QUESTIONS THAT ARE
HOPEFUL WILL BE ABLE TO GET TO
NEUTRAL IN THE COMING DAYS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
APPRECIATE THAT OKAY. SO- LET'S
GO TO FOR LINES TO FROM WHO
WANT TO BE CONCERN ARE. TO THIS
BILL AB. SIX TWO. TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION ONE ZERO AT THIS.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY NOW TO PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. WE HAVE A LINE
QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
PROVIDE THEM THEIR LINE NUMBER.
I'M MODERATOR ANY MINUTE NO ONE
ELSE. YEAH WE DO HAVE A LINE IN
Q. LINE ONE HUNDRED GO AHEAD
PLEASE. MORNING SHARE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ADAM WRIGLEY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE CURRENTLY HAVE A
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
BUT THAT WOULD BE UTHORS-
INTEND TO WORK ON THE INTENSELY
ADDED DEFINITION. WERE LIKELY
TO MOVE TO NEUTRAL ONCE WE SEE
THAT LANGUAGE IN CURRENT BUT-
REALLY APPRECIATE WORKING WITH
THAT THE OFFERINGS THAT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU OKAY IF. FEB
HAVE BELIEVE AS JUST ONE PERSON
MIND SO LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
THE LINE OVER THE LINES INTO
SIR THANK YOU THANK YOU MATTER
OKAY SO IT'S BEEN BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS THOUGHTS. I SEE ONE
COMMENT OR QUESTION FROM
SENATOR ALI. THANK YOU TAKE
YOUR SHARE SO. I ACTUALLY JUST
WANNA CLARIFICATION AND I KNOW
WE WORKED ON P. VOSS. IN IT WAS
LAST YEAR MAYBE THE YEAR BEFORE
WITH YOU KNOW THE FIREFIGHTERS
AND THEN TRYING TO. GIVE THEM
AN OPPORTUNITY TO COME UP WITH
NEW TECHNOLOGY TO COME WITHOUT
THAT THE DEPTH OF THE TO
IMPLEMENT IT SO IT WAS A PHASE
IN TIME. BUT I MY QUESTION IS
AND- FORGIVE ME FOR MIGHT BE
NOT AS- EDUCATED ON THIS ISSUE
AS I WANT TO BE- WHY DO WE HAVE
TO HAVE PEOPLE AS IN THE FIRST
PLACE WHAT IS IT IS ISN'T
TERRIBLE I WANTED I RECALL AND-
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG MAYBE
ONE OF THE- WITNESSES COULD
HELP ME OUT THAT THERE WAS. A
TIME WHEN WE WERE TRYING TO
STOP THINGS FROM BURNING IS
FAST- AND THAT'S WHY IT WAS
INCORPORATED INTO OUR- CHAIRS
AND CARPET AND- CLOTHING- AND
SO. IT IS THAT IS THAT THE CASE
THAT WE HAVE THOSE SOME LAW IN
THE BOOK THE SAYS SOMETHING
CAN'T BURN AS FAST AS IT WOULD
NOT OR WOULD OTHERWISE WITHOUT
PEOPLE SENATE. SO THAT IF YOU
CAME UP WITH FLAME RETARDANTS
WHICH HAVE ALREADY BEEN REMOVED
FROM CHILDREN'S PRODUCTS. THIS
P. FOSS IS USED FOR EVEN A- YOU
KNOW SORT OF LESS IMPORTANT
REASON IT'S REALLY ROUTINELY
BEEN SPRAYED ON A LOT OF THESE
PRODUCTS BECAUSE THEY THINK
IT'S MAKES IT MORE STAIN
RESISTANT. WHICH IS SOMEONE
THAT HAS A LOT OF THESE
PRODUCTS WILL TELL YOU I DON'T
EVEN BELIEVE THAT- BECAUSE
EVERYTHING GETS STAINED. BUT
IT'S CERTAINLY THERE'S NO LAW
THAT SAYS THAT. THAT THEY NEED
TO. MAKE A CAR SEAT MORE STRAIN
RESISTANT THERE'S FOR CLOTHING
AND OTHER PRODUCTS ARE
CERTAINLY OTHER MATERIALS THAT
ARE USED BY A LOT OF INCOME
COMPANIES IF YOU BUY ORGANIC
MATERIALS A LOT OF TIMES THEY
HAVE OTHER TYPES OF. YOU KNOW
THINGS ON THEM THAT WOULD HELP
MAKE IT A LITTLE SLICKER WHEN
YOU WASH IT SO UNLIKE WITH
FLAME RETARDANTS WHICH AT ONE
POINT WHERE I THINK WERE
MANDATED BY LAW. NONE OF THIS
IS IMPACTED BY ANY REGULATIONS
AND WE'VE EXEMPTED THINGS THAT
WE THINK THERE IS AN ARGUMENT
FOR SOME OF THE ELECTRONICS FOR
INSTANCE AND- THINGS THAT ARE
INSIDE- INSIDE THESE PRODUCTS
SO. IF THAT YOUR QUESTION IF
YOUR QUESTION IS WHETHER
THEY'RE USING IT BECAUSE OF ANY
LAW THAT REQUIRES THEM TO THE
ANSWER IS NO. SO- SO THIS BILL
BASICALLY IS DEFINING DOES IF
IT WANTS TO WE ARE PROP SIXTY
FIVE WHICH LATE THAT'S A
LABELING ISSUE AND LETTING THE
CONSUMERS KNOW WHAT THE RISK IS
OF USING THE PRODUCTS SO THAT
DOES NOT THIS BILL DOES NOT
TOUCH THAT IS STILL GOING TO BE
LABELED- THIS BILL BASICALLY IS
NEARING IN ON THOSE- VERY.
DEFINED PRODUCTS THAT ARE ONLY
FOR CHILDREN CORRECT YOUR
HEALTH PRODUCTS. SO PEOPLE ALSO
STILL BE USED I AM PLEASED TO
ANNOUNCE IS FOR ADULT
MATTRESSES WHICH SO IF YOUR
CHILD IS. SLEEPING WITH YOU IN
YOUR BED YOUR THEY'RE STILL
GOING TO BE. SUSCEPTIBLE TO THE
PEOPLE ASSETS AND- ALL THE
ADULT PRODUCTS CORRECT AND I
THINK IT'S A REAL CONCERN.
THANK YOU CHAIR THANK YOU- THE
REQUESTED I MUST SAY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AT THAT POINT I
NATIONALLY HEARD ABOUT THIS
BILL AND ANOTHER SORT OF A
KNOCKOFF OF GREEN CHEMISTRY
WHILE I SHARE YOUR FRUSTRATION
TED IT'S MOVING SLOWER THAN ALL
OF US HAVE ANTICIPATED- IS
STILL DOING GOOD WORK I THINK
WHAT I HEARD TODAY AND FROM THE
STAFF REPORT BECAUSE WHAT. WHAT
MAKES. IT'S TO GIVE YOU THE
BENEFIT OF MY THINKING THE-
DGSE IS ALREADY MADE A DECISION
ON THE RUGS AND CARPETS WHAT
DID. A P. FAST AND I'VE ALSO
MADE A DECISION ON. PLANT BASED
FOOD PACKAGING SO THIS IS THIS
IS GREEN CHEMISTRY WORKING AND
NOW SAYING BECAUSE OF THE
INFANT AND JUVENILE PRODUCTS WE
WANT TO EXTEND THAT SCIENCE
THAT WE HAVE DONE THAT BODY
SCIENCE TO IT. I THINK THAT'S
REFLECTED IN SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION THAT HAVE SAID OKAY
THAT'S A NATURAL PROGRESSION
VERSUS JUST. WE THOUGHT WE JUST
FOUND NEW CHEMICAL AND WE
WANTED TO BE WE WANT TO GO TO
THE FRONTLINE AND I. AND GREEN
CHEMISTRY SO I APPRECIATE THAT
I DID I'M SORRY I WASN'T HERE
TO BEGINNING BUT I DID HEAR
SOME. BECAUSE THE THINGS THAT
PEOPLE ARE SAYING ABOUT THE-
INTENTIONAL- N. IF I IF I COULD
HEAR FROM YOU I'M SORRY IF IT'S
REPETITIVE VALERIE MENTION THAT
YOU REMARKS WHERE DO YOU THINK
THAT THAT'S COULD LAND. ON IT'S
NOT. IT'S IT IS IT THE
NATURALLY OCCURRING INTENTION.
OR IS IT THAT THAT'S ADDED TO
THE PRODUCTS- FOR THESE
JUVENILE PRODUCTS. YEAH I WELL
WE HAVE TAKEN- THE LANGUAGE
THAT WE TOOK FROM THE COMMITTEE
WAS TO GIVE MORE CERTAINTY TO
THAT MANUFACTURERS IN THAT
REGARD. SO THAT THEY FELT THAT
THEY WOULDN'T BE- SORT OF. THEY
WOULD NEVER PUNITIVE ACTION
AGAINST THEM WHEN THEY DID NOT
KNOW THAT THERE WAS PEOPLE ALSO
WAS NATURALLY OCCURRING. OR
THERE WAS OTHER KIND OF
CONTAMINATION. SO WE'RE HOPEFUL
THAT THAT WILL REMOVE THEIR
OPPOSITION AS YOU HER I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU WERE IF YOU WERE
CAME IN AS THEY WERE SPEAKING.
THEY CERTAINLY HAVE TO GO BACK
TO THEIR MEMBERS TO. MAKE SURE
THAT ALL OF THEIR ISSUES ARE
ADDRESSED AND YOU KNOW WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS
WORKABLE FOR INDUSTRY AS WELL-
THE SO- YOU KNOW I THINK THAT
THEY'RE JUST CONCERNED ABOUT
LIABILITY WHEN THEY IF THEY
MAKE ALL THE BEST EFFORTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT. THAT THIS
MATERIAL IS NOT THERE. AND IT
COMES FROM THE INSIDE OF THE
PRODUCT OR SOMETHING HAPPENS
THAT THEY'LL HAVE A CHANCE T
CORRECT THAT. AND IT'S
CONSISTENT WITH THE LARA
LANGUAGE THAT DAY THAT WE HAD
CORRECT IN YOUR SYSTEM THAT
LIKE EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT. THEY
UNDERSTAND THEY KNOW HOW TO
WORK WITHIN SO- WE'VE BEEN YOU
KNOW WE REALLY HAVE BEEN
WORKING VERY HARD TO REMOVE.
THE SMALL AMOUNT OF OPPOSITION
THAT THEY HAD AND I WOULD LIKE
TO THIS POINT OUT THAT THEIR
OPPOSITION WAS NOT ABOUT THE
INTENT OF THIS BILL. I WILL
GIVE INDUSTRY A LOT OF CREDIT
FOR SAYING HEY WE GET THAT THIS
IS A PROBLEM WE DON'T WANT TO
SEE THIS ANYMORE EITHER WE
UNDERSTAND THE EMERGING. DATA
SCIENCE ABOUT THE RISKS OF THIS
WE WANT TO GET THIS OUT OF OUR
PRODUCTS NOW WE JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT. YOU KNOW THAT
WE DO IT IN A WAY THAT WE THAT.
WE CAN ACHIEVE SO THEY'VE BEEN
REALLY GOOD ABOUT WORKING WITH
US ON THAT. I'M OF THE BILL.
THE SENATE. THIRTY DOLLAR. THE
FOLLOW UP. THAT'S VERY GOOD
INFORMATION AND- BOB BILL LATE
IT FREES THERE USING RECYCLED
MATERIAL HAD THE PEOPLE SENATE
BEFORE THE I MEAN THEY THEY
NEED TO BE HELD HARMLESS TO TRY
DOING THE BEST EFFORT TO
ELIMINATE THE PRODUCTS AND SO-
I COMMENDED THE ABILITY TO WORK
TOGETHER I'M ONLY OFF THE
BUILDING TO SEE WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO PROCS NEXT I BELIEVE.
THERE WAS A- IT- I THINK ONE OF
FOR. SO ARE YOU GONNA BE TAKEN
MINUTES BEFORE THE FLOOR WELL
WE FIRST WANT TO SEE IF THEY-
AGREED TO THE LANGUAGE THAT WE
PUT IN IT'S POSSIBLE THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO YOU KNOW DO
THEY DO THAT DEEP DIVE INTO THE
LANGUAGE GO BACK TO THE MEMBERS
AND COME BACK AND REMOVE THEIR
OPPOSITION THAT'S OUR HOPE.
OKAY THANK YOU. OKAY BRADFORD
BATES I JUST SAYS CLOTHING I
JUST WANT TO THANK OUR-
ASSEMBLY WOMAN. FRIEDMAN FOR
THE WORK ON THIS BECAUSE I
THINK YOU'VE RAISED A
SIGNIFICANT ISSUES AND ALL OF
US AS PARENTS. YOU KNOW HAVE
THOSE LITTLE GUYS. ALONG THE
WAY THIS IS SOUND REALLY. SCARY
TESTIMONY THAT THESE ARE THINGS
THAT WILL AFFECT THEM I'M GONNA
LAY OFF TODAY BUT I WANT TO
COMMEND YOU FOR. THE WORK
YOU'VE DONE AND I THINK BY THE
TIME IT GETS TO THE FLOOR IF
IT'S ON THE PROBES. WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT HAPPENS IN APPROACH
THAT COULD BE SUSPENSE BUT-
I'D- I WILL. MOST LIKELY BE
THERE ARE FOR THE MOST
IMPORTANT VOTE. THANK YOU AND
YOU'VE DONE A GREAT JOB ON
THIS. THANK YOU SENATOR. GREAT
THANK YOU. WE'LL SEE ANOTHER
COMMENTS ONE THIRTY OUT FOR.
HER WORK ON THIS. IMPORTANT
ISSUE AND SO MANY OTHERS AND
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SONORA
CASKEY WILL LET YOU CLOSE THIS
SUMMER. THAT'S ALL I JUST A YOU
KNOW POINT OUT WE HAVE. ON THE
FLOOR WE HAD NO NO VOTES ON THE
VOTE ON THE BILL AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT OF
COMMENTS AND WE WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH WITH INDUSTRY WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS
DOABLE FOR THEM. SO THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED TO CONSULT
PLEASE KALRA. ITEM NUMBER TWO
AB SIX FIVE TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED.
ALAN HI. ALAN HI BATES. DALLY
GONZALEZ SKINNER STERN Y.
CASKEY HI I. CASKEY I'M- REALLY
THE ROLE OPEN FOR FOLKS THAT
HONESTY SILVA- BLOOM HERE HE
CAN PRESENT AB TEN SIXTY SIX. A
VERY IMPORTANT NUMBER FOR A-
FOR BRITS. THE BATTLE OF
HASTINGS. SO- YOUR EYES ONE
APPRECIATE- YOUR YOUR TO
CHOOSING THAT FOR TWO IT IS
NUMBER MY FATHER WHO MAY BE
WATCHING THIS HEARING IS- IS
PLEASED. MISTER ALONE SO LET'S
HEAR FROM USING YOUR DATA MAY
BE MORE IMPORTANT THAN THAT
PLEASING YOU MISTER CHAIR YES.
THAT'S RESERVE. FIVE MAY I
PROCEED YES PLEASE THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CO
AUTHORSHIP OF THIS BILL AND
JENNIFER IT'S BECAUSE OF ME
BECAUSE OF THE NUMBER. OF HI
AND I WOULD ALSO THINK OF
COURSE COMMITTEE STAFF- WHOSE
EFFORTS HAVE BEEN DILIGENT TEND
TO- WE FIVE. WORK WELL IN THE
BAG- I KNOW THAT- YOUR STAFF IS
ALSO WORKED WITH OUR SPONSOR
HEAL THE BAY. THE AB TEN SIXTY
SIX PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH BY
TAKING THE FIRST STEPS TO
CREATING A UNIFORM SET OF
STATEWIDE MONITORING STANDARDS
AND PROTOCOLS FOR TESTING
BACTERIA IN PRIORITY FRESH
WATER BODIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. UNLIKE OUR COASTAL
WATERS CALIFORNIA'S RIVERS
LAKES AND STREAMS ARE NOT
MONITORED FOR RECREATIONAL
WATER QUALITY IN THE SAME
MANNER AS OCEAN BEACHES. IN
ADDITION THE SMALL AMOUNT OF
DATA AND MONITORING THAT IS
DONE IT IS MOST OFTEN NOT
CURRENT OR READILY AVAILABLE TO
THE PUBLIC. BECAUSE RIVERS
LAKES AND STREAMS ARE NOT BEING
ROUTINELY MONITORED THOUSANDS
OF VISITORS TO FRESH WATER
RECREATION SITES MAY BE
UNWITTINGLY EXPOSED TO
CONTAMINATED WATER. RATHER THAN
ATTEMPT TO ESTABLISH AN STATUTE
WHICH SITES NEED TO BE TESTED
AB TEN SIXTY SIX REQUIRES THAT
THE CALIFORNIA WATER QUALITY
MONITORING COUNCIL. BY JULY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO DIRECT
A NEW OR EXISTING WORKING GROUP
TO STUDY WATER RECREATION
HAZARDS AT PRIORITY WATER
CONTACT RECREATION SITES. THE
WORKING GROUP IS TO CONDUCT
THOSE STUDIES OVER A TWELVE
MONTH PERIOD BEFORE SUBMITTING
A REPORT OF THEIR FINDINGS TO
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD THE COUNCIL WILL
THEN IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS
AND THE PUBLIC PROPOSED TO THE
STATE WATER BOARD TO CONSIDER A
DEFINITION OF MONITORED FRESH
ROCK FRESHWATER RECREATION SITE
AND THE SHOULD HAPPEN ON OR
BEFORE DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. AB TEN
SIXTY SIX IS MODELED AFTER A B.
FOUR ONE ONE WHICH WAS SIGNED
INTO LAW IN NINETEEN NINETY
SEVEN. AND ESTABLISHED
REQUIREMENTS FOR REGULAR STATE
AND LOCAL MONITORING OF COASTAL
WATERS. AND INFORM THE PUBLIC
WHEN THE WATERS POSED A HEALTH
HAZARD. AND LET ME POINT OUT
THAT THIS IS NOT A COSTLY NEW
STATE PROGRAM WHAT IT DOES IS
BUILD ON WORK THAT'S ALREADY
BEING DONE BY THE S. W. R. C.
B. AND MANY PUBLIC PRIVATE AND
PRIVATE AND PRIVATE. SECTOR
FRESHWATER RECREATION SITE
MANAGERS BY IMPROVING GREATER
CONSISTENCY AND TRANSPARENCY.
CURRENTLY THOSE PUBLIC CA AND
PRIVATE MANAGERS I JUST DON'T
HAVE CONSISTENT TESTING
PROTOCOLS AND METHODOLOGIES. AB
TEN SIXTY SIX FIXES KEY
ELEMENTS OF THIS HEALTH PROBLEM
BY ESTABLISHING UNIFORM
MONITORING STANDARDS WHILE ALSO
ADDRESSING INEQUITY ISSUE
INLAND AREAS SHOULD BE AFFORDED
THE SAME PUBLIC HEALTH
PROTECTIONS AS COASTAL AREAS.
WE RECOGNIZE. I SHOULD SAY OF
COURSE ARE THERE ARE MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS AND VISITORS
WHO RELY ON FRESH WATER BODIES
LIKE LAKES RIVERS AND STREAMS
FOR RECREATION AND THEY SHOULD
HAVE THE SAME PROTECTION THAT
FOLKS WHO HAD OUT TO OUR
BEACHES HALF THE BEACH
MONITORING PROGRAM HAS BEEN A
RESOUNDING SUCCESS AROUND THE
STATE- AND WE KNOW THAT- MISTER
CHAIR UNITE- BECAUSE IT'S BEEN
A SUCCESS RIGHT AT HOME IN OUR
BEACH AND US. IN SANTA MONICA
WHERE WE NOW UNDERSTAND THE
WATER QUALITY ISSUES- POOR
WATER QUALITY ISSUES FRANKLY
THAT CAME FROM STORMWATER
RUNOFF THAT CAME FROM RESIDUE
THAT WAS COMING OFF OF THE
SANTA MONICA PIER ONCE YOU KNOW
THOSE THINGS YOU CAN LET PEOPLE
KNOW WHEN THEY'RE BAD WHEN
THEY'RE PROBLEMATIC SO THAT
SURFERS AND- BAY THIS
CONSPIRATORIAL- AND IT ALSO
ELEVATES PUBLIC UNDERSTANDING
ABOUT THE- THE ISSUE- AND
MOTIVATES. LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN
THE STATE TO TAKE ACTION TO
CLEAN UP THE PROBLEMS WHICH
WE'VE DONE IN SANTA MONICA TO
GREAT EFFECT. YEP WE RECOGNIZE
THE TEN SIXTY SIX IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS AND IS ONLY THE FIRST
STEP IN ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE
THE BILL WILL ADDRESS A KEY
PUBLIC HEALTH CHALLENGE THAT
MANY CALIFORNIANS FACE AN
OUTDOOR RECREATION ENSURING
THAT THERE ARE SIGNS AND HEALTH
BASED MICROBIOLOGICAL STANDARDS
ONGOING WATER QUALITY
MONITORING AND PUBLIC
NOTIFICATION FOR FRESH WATER
RECREATION WHERE NEEDED
CALIFORNIA IS A MAGNIFICENT
STATE ONE THAT AFFORDS ALL OUR
COMMUNITIES WITH OPPORTUNITIES
TO RECREATION OUTDOORS NOT TO
MENTION THOSE WHO COME. TO
VISIT OUR GREAT STATE. POSTED
ENSURE LAKES RIVERS AND STREAMS
DESERVE THE SAME ASSURANCES
THAT FRESHWATER SITES ARE SAFE
TO SWIM AND JUST AS THOSE WHO
ENJOY OUR COASTAL BEACHES.
CALLING IN TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL ARE
KATHERINE PEASE DIRECTOR OF
SCIENCE AND POLICY IF YOU'LL
THE BAY AND MATTHEW THOMAS
OUTREACH ASSOCIATE AT ACTIVE
SAN GABRIEL VALLEY. PLEASE
PROCEED WITH THEIR WITNESSES.
THIRTY CATHARINE. THANK YOU.
THE MORNING CARE ALLEN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS DR
CATHERINE P. IS AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF FINE QUALITY AN
OUTREACH AND HEAL THE BAY. OKAY
IS PROUD TO BE SPONSORING AB
TEN SIXTY SIX WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM AND GREATLY
APPRECIATE SHARE ALLEN CO
AUTHORSHIP. OVER THE RECENT
HOLIDAY WEEKENDS PEOPLE ALL
ACROSS CALIFORNIA FLOCKED TO
BEACHES AND RIVERS TO COOL OFF
AND ENJOY TIME WITH FRIENDS AND
FAMILY. HOWEVER CALIFORNIANS
WHO WENT TO OCEAN BEACHES WERE
AFFORDED MORE PROTECTIONS
REGARDING WATER QUALITY AND
THOSE WHO WENT TO FRESH WATER
RECREATION SITE LIKE RIVERS
CREEKS COMPLAINING ALL. THE
WATER IN MANY OCEAN BEACHES
CAPTAIN REGULARLY FOR BACTERIAL
POLLUTION AND THAT INFORMATION
IS MADE AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC. THE SAME IS NOT TRUE
BURKE FRESHWATER RECREATION
SITE. AB TEN SIXTY SIX TAKES
THE FIRST IMPORTANT STEPS IN
ADDRESSING THIS DISPARITY.
HILDA MAY LEAD THE EFFORT OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO GET BASIC
HEALTH PROTECTIONS FOR OCEAN
BEACH GOERS. THANKS TO A BEFORE
ELEVEN WHICH PASSED THE
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN VISITORS
TO OVER FIVE HUNDRED OF
CALIFORNIA'S BELOVED BEACHES
ARE BETTER PROTECTED BECAUSE
THEY ARE INFORMED ON THE AMOUNT
OF BACTERIAL POLLUTION IN THE
WATER. INCREASED AND
STANDARDIZED MONITORING AT OUR
BEACHES HAS LED TO FURTHER
LEGISLATION THAT PROVIDED
FUNDING FOR PROJECTS. TO
IMPROVE WATER QUALITY AND
FURTHER PUBLIC EDUCATION THAT
KEEPS PEOPLE SAFE. SO THE BAY
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM IS NOW
LEADING THE EFFORT TO ACHIEVE
HEALTH PROTECTIONS FOR VISITORS
TO FRESHWATER SITES. AB TEN
FIFTY SIX WHAT PASSED THE
CALIFORNIA WATER QUALITY
MONITORING COUNCIL BUT DEFINING
AND IDENTIFYING PRIORITY
FRESHWATER RECREATION RIGHT
ACROSS THE STATE. AS WELL AS
MAKING RECOMMENDATIONS FOR AN
APPROPRIATE MONITORING PROGRAM
FOR THE SITE. THIS IS NOT A
MONITORING AND PUBLIC
NOTIFICATION MANDATE LIKE IT
BEFORE ELEVEN BUT IT IS A
CRITICAL FIRST STEP IN
ACHIEVING THOSE HEALTH
PROTECTIONS FOR FRESH WATER.
CHILDREN MAY SUPPORT THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL NAMELY
EXPANDING TO MORE BROADLY
ADDRESSED MICROBIOLOGICAL
STANDARDS. FOCUSING EFFORTS ON
OVERBURDENED COMMUNITIES AND
SHIFTING FROM HIGH USED TO
PRIORITY APPROACH. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND THE AUTHOR TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS WIDESPREAD
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. AB TEN
SIXTY SIX THE FIRST STEP
TOWARDS PROTECTING ALL
CALIFORNIANS FROM POLLUTION AT
THEIR FAVORITE SWIMMING HOLE.
IN IT HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
INSPIRE MORE HEALTH PROTECTION
AND WATER QUALITY IMPROVEMENTS
AS WE HAVE SEEN AT OUR OCEAN
BEACHES. WE URGE YOU TO VOTE
YESTERDAY ON AB TEMP SIXTY SIX
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU SO MUCH LET'S MAKE SURE FOR
MATTHEW THOMAS. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING CHALLENGE AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MATTHEW
THOMAS I'M AN OUTREACH SERVICE
YET ACTIVE SAN GABRIEL VALLEY A
PLACE BASED NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION HEADQUARTERED IN
THE CITY OF EL MONTE. ACTIVE
STV'S MISSION IS TO SUPPORT A
MORE SUSTAINABLE EQUITABLE AND
LIVE THE LIVABLE SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY. BASIC ELEMENTS OF A
LIVABLE COMMUNITY INCLUDE CLEAN
AIR AND CLEAN WATER. THE SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY IS HOME TO A
WATERSHED WITH OVER ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILES OF RIVERS
STREAMS AND WASHES THE LARGEST
OF THESE THANK GABRIEL AND REAL
ON THE RIVERS. SERVICE
SIGNIFICANT RECREATIONAL. AREAS
FOR A JEEP AND PARKOUR AND
POLLUTION BURDEN COMMUNITIES.
ACTIVISTS TV STRONGLY SUPPORTS
A. B. TEN SIXTY SIX BECAUSE IT
TAKES THE NECESSARY FIRST STEPS
IN ADDRESSING THE CASE THE
EXISTING PUBLIC HEALTH
DISPARITY IN CALIFORNIA BETWEEN
PROTECTIONS ACCORDED TO OCEAN
BEACH GOERS. AND THOSE AFFORDED
TO VISITORS BY RIVERS STREAMS
AND LAKES- OCEAN BEACHES WITH A
CERTAIN NUMBER OF VISITORS AND
PROXIMITY TO STORM DRAINS
REQUIRE REGULAR TESTING OF THE
WATER FOR BACTERIAL POLLUTION
AS WELL AS PUBLIC NOTIFICATION.
THE WATER QUALITY. TODAY PEOPLE
STILL GET SICK FROM FRESHWATER
RECREATION BECAUSE CALIFORNIA'S
ICONIC RIVERS LAKES AND STREAMS
ARE NOT MONITORED CONSISTENTLY
BACTERIAL POLLUTION. THE
REQUESTED BY THE CDC AND
ACADEMIC RESEARCHERS INDICATES
THAT THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA GET SICK FROM
FRESHWATER RECREATION EVERY
YEAR. FOR CALIFORNIANS WHO DO
NOT LIVE NEAR THE COASTER FOR
WHOM THE COAST IS NOT EASILY
ACCESSIBLE INLAND FRESHWATER
AREAS PROVIDE ESSENTIAL
RECREATIONAL SPACE FOR SWIMMING
WEEDING AND OTHER FORMS WATER
CONTACT RECREATION.
CALIFORNIANS TO USE THESE
WATERWAYS SHOULD BE PROVIDED
WITH THE SAME PROTECTIONS AT
OCEAN BEACH GOERS ARE GIVEN. WE
WORRY THAT THE CURRENT LACK OF
PUBLIC HEALTH INFORMATION BE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
DISEMPOWERED COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR RECREATION LAKES RIVERS
AND STREAMS. WE SUPPORT THE
MOST RECENT VERSION OF THE BILL
PARTICULARLY THE AMENDMENT
INCLUDING OVERBURDENED
COMMUNITIES AND THE CRITERIA
FOR DEFINING A PRIORITY WATER
CONTACT RECREATION PLACE.
ACTIVIST U. V. BELIEVES THE TEN
SIXTY SIX WILL BE A CRITICAL
STEP FORWARD IN MAKING IN MANY
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING THE SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY IN ITS WATER
BODIES. MORE LIVABLE AND SAFER
FOR COMMUNITY MEMBERS WE ASKED
FOR AN AYE VOTE TODAY TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
IMPROVE WATER QUALITY. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU
MISTER THOMAS PROJECT THAT OKAY
LET'S GO TO THE PHONE LINES
ANYONE WANTS VOICE SUPPORT FOR
A BI TEN SIXTY SIX. MODERATOR
HIS BIGGEST SUPPORT OF AB TEN
SIX. ARE NEEDED TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TEN SIXTY SIX.
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE MOMENT PLEASE WE DO
HAVE A LINE CHEWING UP WILL
PROVIDE THEIR LINE NUMBER. WE
WILL FIRST GO TO LINE SIXTY GO
AHEAD PLEASE. WARNING THIS
INSURED MEMBERS JOHNSON ALONE
ON BEHALF OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH ADMINISTRATORS N STRONG
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE WILL BRING
SOME EQUITY SOME SCIENCE BASED
DECISION MAKING ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT BE SOME CONSISTENCY
IN THAT PROTECTING THE
FRESHWATER BATHING RECREATIONAL
SITES IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
BY LAUREL. FOR GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS SHARON
GREEN WITH THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SANITATION DISTRICT HERE
IN SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU.
NINE ONE OH SEVEN. THE
ALLIANCE'S NURSING THROUGHOUT
THE ENVIRONMENT SHOULD WE
SUPPORT. IF THERE ARE ANY OTHER
VOICES IN SUPPORT PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
GREAT THANK YOU OKAY SO WE'RE
GONNA GO- THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION- REGISTER NO LEAD
OPPOSITION IS OR ANYONE THE
PHONE LINES LIKE TO EXPRESS
THEIR OPPOSITION OR CONCERNS
ABOUT THIS BILL MODERATOR. YOU
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY NOW TO PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE KNOWN
QUEUED UP THANK YOU LET'S BRING
THE ITEM BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS THOUGHTS
COMMENTS. CENTER DOLLY. THANK
YOU SENATOR BOOM FOR BRING THIS
FOR I HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS ON
THE DETAILS OF HOW IT'S GOING
TO ROLL OUT SOMEBODY WHO
REPRESENTS. LAKE TAHOE AND-
THOUSANDS OF MILES OF RIVERS
THAT RUN. AND STREAM THAT RUNS
REGISTER CAL HOUSING- SO WITH
THIS BILL- OBVIOUSLY FOR THE
BEACHES IT'S PRETTY EASY
THERE'S ONE COASTLINE AND BUT
THERE'S LOTS OF TRIBUTARIES
THAT BRANCH OFF THROUGHOUT THE
DAY MY DISTRICT WHAT WHAT DO
YOU THINK THE PROCESS IS GOING
TO LOOK LIKE I MEAN AND THIS
BILLS LIKE GIVING SOME GUIDANCE
TO THE WATER BORDER LIKE
DETERMINE- SO WHAT'S THE
DEFINITION OF A BEACH WHAT'S
THE DEPOSITION OF THIS OF
COURSE SO I GUESS FOR ME IT'S
LIKE. WHO'S GOING TO DO WHAT
AND- HOW THE PROCESS GOING TO
GO FORWARD. WELL UNDER THE BILL
THE WATER BOARD IS SET- CHARGED
WITH SETTING UP THAT PROCESS
AND CARRYING IT THROUGH AND WE
PROVIDE. SOME GUIDANCE AND TIME
LIMITS- TO GET WITHIN WHICH
THAT WORK IS TO BE DONE. I
THINK FOR MORE DETAIL PROBABLY-
A DOCTOR PIZZA AT HEAL THE BAY
MAY BE ABLE TO ADD SOME
ADDITIONAL DETAIL. SURE I CAN
ADD TO THAT THANK YOU. SO IN
TERMS OF THE ATTENDING THE
DEFINITION I THINK THERE IS
SOME SUGGESTION AND SOME
SUGGESTIONS AND THE BILL
LANGUAGE WHERE INDIFFERENT
CRITERIA COULD BE TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT TO- SET FORTH WHAT
WOULD BE A PRIORITY RECREATION
PLIGHT THE CLEARLY IT WE
WOULDN'T EXPECT MONITORING TO
HAPPEN AT. YOU KNOW EVERY
SINGLE SITE ON THE RIVER WHERE
THERE'S ANY SORT OF RECREATION
BUT WE WOULD TRY TO PRIORITIZE
THOSE AREAS THAT WOULD BE BASED
ON THINGS LIKE. HOW USE THEY
GET WHETHER THEY'RE IS I THANK
WATER CALL CONCERNS. WHETHER
THERE IS A LOCATION THAT ARE
USED FOR A COMMERCIAL.
ENDEAVORS LIKE. RAFTING OR
OTHER KINDS OF THINGS LIKE THAT
AS WELL AS THE IT BY
OVERBURDENED COMMUNITIES SO.
THAT THE IN THE CALIFORNIA
WATER QUALITY MONITORING
COUNCIL WOULD SET UP A WORK
GROUP THAT WOULD WORK THROUGH
THOSE ISSUES IN TERMS OF WHAT
WOULD BE THE CRITERIA THAT
WOULD QUALIFY. RIGHT TO. I'VE
ACTUALLY BE MONITORED. THAT
WOULD BE SAFE TO SAY. A LONG
MOST OF THESE TRIBUTARIES THERE
RT THERE'S A LOT OF MONITORING
GOING ON ALREADY FOR THE OXYGEN
AND- FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
DROPPING OUT OF THE SO WITH
THAT INFORMATION IS ALREADY
AVAILABLE STE BE USED TO
DETERMINE WHETHER YOU. NEED
EVEN GOING FURTHER. WHAT I'M
LOOKING FOR THAT ONE ANOTHER
LAYER OF BUREAUCRACY ON TOP OF
WHAT WE ALREADY HAVE. A LOT OF
MONITORING GOING ON IT MOST OF
THE STREAMS AND RIVERS IN MY
DISTRICT HAVE. A MUNICIPALITIES
THAT ARE PULLING OUT OF THOSE
OR PUTTING STUFF BACK IN AND
THEN WE HAVE MONITORING THAT'S
IT ALREADY AVAILABLE THAT WE
WOULD NOT REQUIRE A NOTHER. AND
THEN THERE'S RECREATION ALONG
THOSE TRIBUTARIES THAT WE WOULD
NOT REQUIRE THAT THAT WOULD BE
SUFFICIENT IF THEY USE THE
MONITORING THE PROBLEM THOSE
MINUTES APOLOGIES. THE BILL
ACTUALLY KNOWLEDGE IS THAT THAT
IS- HI IN FACT THE CASE-
HOWEVER WE KNOW THAT OTHER
MONITORING CUT THAT'S GOING ON
IS NOT ALWAYS CONSISTENT
STANDARDS SO ONE OF THE EFFORTS
HERE SHOULD BE TO- I HAVE A
CONSISTENT SET OF STANDARDS SO
THAT ONE GOES FROM ONE. AREA TO
THE NEXT- YOUR- YOU'RE GETTING
A REPORT THAT HAS SOME
CONSISTENCY. TO IT. HI AND- SO
I THINK THAT'S AT LEAST
PARTIALLY IN RESPONSE TO YOUR
TO YOUR QUESTION. THANK YOU.
SENATE BATES A YEAR FOR THANK
YOU I THINK CONSERVE
CONCEPTUALLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BILLION I IT'S REALLY A GOOD
IDEA I THINK IMPRACTICALITY
HOWEVER I'M JUST FOLLOWING UP
ON MY COLLEAGUES FROM BEAVER
ARE WHO MENTIONED- YOU KNOW HOW
MANY TRIBUTARIES AND RIVERS AND
ALL THAT IT'S A KIND OF A
MASSIVE UNDERTAKING AND SOME OF
THE MORE ON NOT ENOUGH AREAS
WHERE WE HAVE THOSE STREAMS AND
LAKES ALONG THE BEACH AREAS I
WAS VERY INVOLVED IN THE
MONITORING CONFIRMED THERE WAS
A LOT OF POLLUTION HERE IN
SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY BEACHES AND
IT TURNED OUT THAT IT WAS THE
BIRDS THAT WERE. THE REAL
PROBLEM SO I GO TO THE QUESTION
OF A WIN THE SOURCES DISCOVERED
AND WE KNOW THAT THERE'S A LOT
OF POLLUTION GOING ON WITH THE
ILLEGAL MARIJUANA GROWING UP IN
THE NORTHERN PART OF OUR STATE
I THINK IT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT THAT ON THIS BOARD
THAT WILL BE BROUGHT TOGETHER-
THAT WE DO HAVE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS I INVOLVED IN
THOSE- AS MENTIONED BY MY
COLLEAGUE THE- OF THE- TESTING
THAT'S ALREADY GOING ON FOR YOU
KNOW OTHER OTHER PURPOSES ALL
OF THOSE PEOPLE NEED TO BE AT
THE TABLE. AND I WOULD ALSO
SUGGEST AND I'M GONNA SUPPORT
IT TODAY BECAUSE I THINK IT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT STEP BUT I THINK
OF THE WORD MANNER IN WHICH IS
PUT TOGETHER IS PROBABLY THE
MOST IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF
THIS BEING WORKABLE DATA SOURCE
IS GOING TO BE AN ISSUE ALL
COSTS IS GOING TO BE AN ISSUE
AND THOSE ARE ALREADY LAYERED-
IN A NUMBER OF AREAS BUT WHEN
YOU DETERMINE THE SOURCE IN THE
PROGRAM OF HOW THAT'S GOING TO
BE CONTROLLED I DO BELIEVE THE
PLAN NEEDS TO BE BROUGHT BACK
THE LEGISLATURE. AND I'D LIKE
TO HAVE SOME COMMITMENT THAT
THAT WOULD BE CONSIDERED
BECAUSE THEY CAN COME UP WITH A
PLAN THAT SOUNDS GREAT BUT WHEN
IT'S IMPOSED ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THEY'RE ALREADY
DOING SOME OF THESE THINGS AND
THE MYRIAD OF SOURCE POTENTIAL
FOR THE POLLUTION OF WHATEVER
RADIOS CAN BE- HUGE HUGE ARE IT
TOOK FOR THE BEACH AREAS I WAS
ON THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FOR
EIGHT YEARS IT TOOK ALMOST.
THAT ENTIRE TIME TO TESTING OUR
TO DETERMINE THAT IT WAS. OF
THE BIRD IN THE SIZE FOR THEM
FOR OF THE CAMPUS- BEECHER.
THAT WE REALLY SOURCE AND IT
WASN'T JUST THE ODD. OUTFLOW
FROM FERTILIZING LAWNS UP UP
AND NOT HIGHLANDS OF. THE FACT
MANY OF SAN JUAN CAPISTRANO
AREA. AND THAT WAS VERY COSTLY
BUT IT WAS VERY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE DOWN THERE WERE-
DEFICIT CAME FORWARD TO
DISCOURAGE THE BIRDS FROM
COLLECTING. IN CERTAIN AREAS.
BUT ANYWAY THOSE ARE THINGS
THAT ARE OF CONCERN AS WE PUT
TOGETHER- A PROGRAM THAT'S
REALLY GOING TO DO THE JOB THAT
YOU HOPE AND THAT WE ALL WANT
DONE- SO I WOULD SUGGEST THAT
REALLY NEEDS COME BACK. HERE
ONCE WE GOT SOMETHING TOGETHER
AND IMPERATIVE. THAT WE HAVE OF
THOSE WHO ARE CURRENTLY
INVOLVED IN ALL OF THAT. THAT
THERE AT THE TABLE. I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THOSE COMMENTS
SENATOR OF THE BILL IN FACT TO
ANTICIPATE SO- THAT THERE WOULD
BE- IMPLEMENTATION- CUT
LEGISLATION REQUIRED. BEFORE
THE PROGRAM ACTUALLY MOVES
FORWARD SO AFTER ALL THIS DATA
IS. COLLECTED AND TO THE
WORKING GROUP DOES ITS WORK
REPORTS BACK TO THE WATER
POURED. WATER BOARD-
ESSENTIALLY MAKES
RECOMMENDATIONS ALTHOUGH I
DON'T THINK THAT'S THE WORD
THAT'S USED- AND THEN THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD HAVE TO ACT.
WELL THANK YOU AND AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING UP FOR. YOU
GREAT. I QUESTIONS- BILLS MOVED
SENATOR. MCCASKEY HI ASSEMBLY
GEORGE CLOSE. IT'S A- A- WELL
KNOWN- ADVERTISING CUT LINE
NOW- BECAUSE- TASK WHAT WHAT'S
IN YOUR WALLET THIS BILL SEEKS
TO ANSWER THE QUESTION WHAT'S
IN YOUR WATER- THAT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTION WE DON'T
KNOW IF MANY CALIFORNIANS DON'T
KNOW THE ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION THEY DESERVE TO KNOW
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU OKAY I'M
CONSUMPTION OR- ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AB TEN SIXTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ALAN HI ALAN I
BATES AYE BATES I'D DALLY.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I SKINNER
STERN Y. CASKEY. BY ASKING I.
OKAY REALLY THAT WILL OPEN FOR
MEMBERS ADD ON- AND I SAW
BECAUSE NUMBER CAN. IS GONNA BE
PRETTY WHEN CARILLO BILL I WERE
ALSO WAITING FOR FILTERING
LET'S LIFT THE CALL ON THE-
JUST TO LET OTHER AT MEMBERS AT
ON CIVIL LET'S SAID WITH THE
CALL ON THE- CONSECUTIVE
CONSULTANT. AND IF WE CAN BE
CALLING BOTH TO THE ASSEMBLY
RETAINS IN THE SUMMER GONZALEZ
IS OFFICES TO HAVE THEM COME
DOWN TO PRESENT. ITS OWN PLEASE
PUT THE CALL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ARE ITEMS ONE SEVEN
AND EIGHT GONZALEZ. AND SALAS I
STERN Y. CASKEY BY ASKI I'D-
START NOW IT SAYS THAT THE OPEN
THE ROLE FOR THE- SB SIX FIFTY
TWO THIS IS A FRIEDMAN SPELL.
THE ITEM NUMBER TWO EIGHTY SIX
FIFTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I AM VICE CHAIR NOT
VOTING THE CURRENT VOTE IS TWO
TO ZERO. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
SKINNER STERN. OKAY LET ME-
ANNOUNCED THE CALL IN NUMBER
AGAIN FOR PEOPLE WHO WANT TO SO
WE GOT THREE MORE BILLS OUT
THIS IS WENDY CARILLO IS AB
SEVEN NINETY FOUR. AND THEN
FILL TEAMS AB TWELVE HUNDRED
TWELVE A ONE- THE JUST REMIND
FOLKS THE CALL IN NUMBERS TO
CALL NUMBERS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
THREE. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE THREE
THE ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN ZERO
FIVE SIX NINE ZERO NINE. AND-
THAT'S FOR FOLKS WHO WANT TO.
CALL IN TO VOICE THEIR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION TO THE THREE
REMAINING BILLS. AB SEVEN
NINETY FOUR BY CARILLO AB
TWELVE HUNDRED BY TEN A. B.
TWELVE A ONE ALSO WRITING. ARE
WE ARE IN TOUCH WITH THE WITH
OFFICES. BECAUSE OF WHICH WERE.
HEY WE ARE FILTERING HERE TO
PRESENT AB TWELVE HUNDRED
TWELVE OH ONE AND THIS IS ITEM
NUMBER FIVE IN YOUR CHEN IS
MEMBERS YOU MAY PERCEIVE AND
READY TO CELEBRATE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR APPRECIATE IT-
PERSONALLY JUST THANK YOU AND
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING
VERY DILIGENTLY WITH OUR TEAM
AND OUR SPONSORS. I AM HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WHICH ADDRESS THE OPPOSITION'S
CONCERN AROUND THE DEFINITION
OF INTENTIONALLY- POTENTIALLY
ADDED EXCUSE ME- THIS THIS BILL
AB TWELVE HUNDRED PROTECT
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS BY
REDUCING HUMAN EXPOSURE TO AN
ENVIRONMENTAL CONTAMINATION
FROM P. FILES. THOUSANDS OF
COMMITTEES VERY WELL WHERE IS
ARE A CLASS OF OVER NINE
THOUSAND FOREVER FOREVER
CHEMICALS HAVE BEEN LINKED TO
ISSUES. SUCH AS CANCER HORMONE
DISRUPTION KIDNEY AND LIVER
DAMAGE AND- MANY OTHER.
DISEASES CURRENTLY P. FAST CAN
BE DETECTED IN 98% OF
AMERICANS- WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THEIR BLOOD. WE'VE SEEN
COMPANIES- TAKE ACTION. WHICH
IS GREAT THESE THESE CHEMICALS
CAN BE FOUND IN TAKE OUT
CONTAINERS COOKWARE- AND
THEY'RE THERE TO PROTECT THE-
TRUMP CONTAINERS SO THAT THE
FOOD. HAS A LEAK ONTO OUR
CLOSER. OUT OF THEIR-
CONTAINERS BUT WE'VE SEEN
INDIVIDUAL COMPANIES LIKE
MCDONALD'S WENDY'S CHIPOTLE
WHOLE FOODS AND OTHER STATES
LIKE NEW YORK. ALREADY TAKE
ACTION TO PHASE OUT OR BAN P.
FASTER FROM THEIR PAPER FOOD
PACKAGING. A RECENT REPORT
FOUND THAT 80% OF NONSTICK PANS
IN 20% A BIG WHERE TESTING
CONTAINING CODY MADE FROM P.
FAST. SAID THIS BILL BANS THE
USE OF INTENTIONALLY ADDED P.
FAST. IN PLANT BASED FOOD
PACKAGING BY TWENTY TWENTY
THREE IT ALSO REQUIRES COOKWARE
MANUFACTURERS TO DISCLOSE THE
USE OF PEOPLE AFTER THE
HAZARDOUS CHEMICALS FROM THE
DTCS CARE TO CHEMICAL THIS. THE
PRODUCTS ONLINE BY TWENTY
TWENTY THREE AND ON PACKAGING
BY TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. AND
PROHIBITS MISLEADING MARKETING
CLAIMS ON COOKWARE CLAIMING TO
BE FREE OF A SPECIFIC.
HAZARDOUS CHEMICAL WHEN OTHER
CYNICAL CHEMICALS ARE PRESENT
ONLINE BY TWENTY TWENTY THREE
IN ON PACKAGING BY TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. WITH THAT WE'RE
HAPPY TO HAVE TWO WITNESSES AND
A READ FROM OUR DC AND- NANCY
BORE MINOR. FROM THE BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS. IF
YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH. THE I
GOOD MORNING CARE AND MY OF THE
AND YOU FOR THAT TO SPEAK WITH
YOU TODAY MY NAME IS TANNER AND
I'M OF ENOUGH RESOURCES
COUNCIL'S WE FIND OUR ENERGY
SUPPORT AB TWELVE HUNDRED TO
RESTRICT THE UNNECESSARY USE
THAT OFTEN IT PACKAGING
INDEPENDENT IS NOT VERY CLEAR
BODIES INCLUDING CALIFORNIANS
ON DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL HAVE
CONCLUDED THAT THE FACT OF THE
CLASS. ACTION BAR MENTAL AND
PUBLIC HEALTH THREAT AND LAST
YEAR THE LEGISLATURE PHASE OUT
THE USE. OF ALL PEACOCK PARK
READING FROM. A COUPLE EARLIER
BY DR ANDREWS. TRANSACTION WE
PUSH. CAN BUILD UP THE OUR
BODIES AND OUR SAYS. WITH A
WIDE ARRAY OF HARM HEALTH.
INCLUDING CANCER SYSTEMS. AND
ADVERSE DEVELOPMENTAL EFFECTS.
BUT IT COVERED IN THE BY THE
HIGH PREVALENCE BUT THE
PACKAGING OF MOLDED FIBER AND
OTHER PLANT BASED PRODUCTS THAT
CONTAIN PIZZA. PRODUCTS CAN
EXPOSE CONSUMERS TO PEOPLE AS
THEY EAT AN OFFICER
CONTAMINATION OF WATER AND FOOD
PRODUCTS THROUGHOUT THEIR
LIFECYCLE ESPECIALLY. DURING
PRODUCTION AND THE WIFE. NUMBER
ONE COMPO CONTAINER WITH
PETOSKEY. PACKAGING FARMERS WHO
USE THAT. IN THEIR FEEL CAN IN
A- CONTAMINATE THEIR GRANDMA
CROP AND LIVESTOCK. A GOOD MAN
THE MULTIPLE COMPANIES BUT
PEOPLE. THREE GOOD PACKAGING
AND INDUSTRY IS GOING TO LEAD A
MAJOR CHAINS LIKE CHIPOTLE
MCDONALD'S AND WHOLE FOODS IN
SMALLER CHAINS LIKE SWEETGREEN
OF ARGUMENT COMMITMENTS AND THE
USE THAT PEOPLE OFTEN LIKE THE
PACKAGING. AND FURTHER LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS SUCH AS SAN
FRANCISCO AND BERKELEY HAVE
ALREADY FACE OUT THE USE OF
PEACOCK CONTAINING THE
PACKAGING. AND PERHAPS MOST
RELEVANT TO THIS BILL NEW YORK
STATE RECENTLY PAN PEACOCK BASS
PACKAGING STARTING IN DECEMBER
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO. DUE TO
THE EXTREME PERSISTENCE OF
THESE CHEMICALS IS NOW GONNA
CONSEQUENCES. FOR DECADES TO
COME GIVEN THE- OF ALL. IT'S
TIME TO THINK ABOUT ON THE USE
OF PIZZA IN THE KEY PRODUCT HOW.
CAN I DO YOU SEE ALSO COULD THE-
TO CORPS OF THE BILL WHICH MY
COLLEAGUE IN THE PRESS CANCER.
PART PREVENTION PARTNERS WILL
DISCUSS THANK. OKAY WHAT'S NOW
HERE FROM. IN READ. NO I'M
SORRY NEEDS HE NEEDS BERMAN AT
THE OUR THREE I'M SORRY I'M
UNABLE NAMES CAN USE NANCY. HE
GOOD MORNING- THANK YOU SURE
AND MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE TOP. TO TEST TO IN OF AB
HUNDRED. MY NAME IS NANCY MEYER
I WORK FOR BREAST FROM PARTNERS.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
BILL'S CO SPONSORS THE CPP
CENTER FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH. CLEAN WATER ACTION
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP AND
NRDC. YOU JUST HEARD FROM AL Y.
P. FAST TO PACKAGING OUR OUR IS
SO CONCERNING AND HOW AB TWELVE
HUNDRED ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE SO
I WILL FOCUS ON THE COOKWARE
PORTION OF THE BILL. RECENT
TESTING FOUND PFAS CHEMICALS
SUCH AS PTSD OFTEN KNOWN BY THE
BRAND NAME TEFLON. IN THE
HORMONE DISRUPTING CHEMICAL
DISNEYLAND OR BPA IN THE
COATINGS OF COOK AND BAKEWARE.
WE KNOW P. FAST CAN BE RELEASED
INTO THE AIR WHEN HANDS REACH
HIGH TEMPERATURES EXPOSING BOTH
PEOPLE AND PETS. HOWEVER NO
DISCLOSURE OF CHEMICALS IN
THESE PRODUCTS IS REQUIRED AT
THE FEDERAL OR STATE LEVEL.
ADDITIONALLY COOKWARE PACKAGING
OFTEN CLAIMS A PRODUCT IS FREE
OF A SPECIFIC P. FILES SUCH AS
PFOA OR PFOS. EVEN CONSUMERS
THE FALSE IMPRESSION THE
PRODUCT IS FREE OF ALL SIMILAR
TOXIC CHEMICALS IN FACT HAND
LABELED P. FOR FREE ARE OFTEN
MADE WITH ANOTHER FORM OF P.
FAST. CONSUMERS HAVE A RIGHT TO
KNOW TOXIC CHEMICALS ARE IN
COOKWARE AND MANUFACTURE SHOULD
NOT BE ALLOWED TO USE MARKETING
CLAIMS TO MISLEAD CONSUMERS. AB
TWELVE HUNDRED ADDRESSES BOTH
OF THESE CONCERNS SHOULD BE
OFFERING BECAUSE DOCTORS HAVE
WORKED EXTENSIVELY WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND OPPOSITION TO
ADDRESS OPPOSITION CONCERNED IF
YOU COULD WIND UP YOUR COMMENTS
OR WERE YOU RUNNING UP AGAINST
THEM. AT THE TIME. OKAY I'LL
JUST SAY IN THE CURRENT FORM IT
PROTECTS PUBLIC HEALTH WITHOUT
UNDULY. BURDENING INDUSTRY AND
WE ASK FOR YOUR EYES. THANK YOU
WE- BOTH BOTH OF THE OF SUPPORT
WHEN HIS TIME IS. TIME IS
TOGETHER SO LET'S LET'S LET'S
GO TO PHONE LINES YOU FOLKS
WANT TO. WIN IN SUPPORT OF IT
WOULD JUST EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT
FOR A BI TWELVE HUNDRED
MODERATOR. TO EXPRESS YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A BI TWELVE HUNDRED
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TOUCH TONE PHONE AT THIS TIME.
WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE SIXTY
FOUR GO AHEAD PLEASE. YEAH.
FIVE SIX FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
GO AHEAD. NINE SIXTY FOUR IF
YOU COULD PLEASE PICK UP YOUR
HANDSET OR CHECK COMMITTEE JR.
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES YES YOU
CAN YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY
NAME IS AGAINST THE LOCAL MAYOR
AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE AND THE ONLINE TRAINING
ECONOMY AND SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVEN NINE FOUR. THANK. NINE
SEVENTY ONE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS DANIEL
BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. BY.
NINETY NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON-
THE MORNING CARE NUMBERS FOR
THOUGHT YOU DON'T ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PRODUCT WHICH
ACCOUNT FOR NATIONAL SECURITY
ACTION COUNCIL CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO AND STOP WAIT
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE
SEVENTY FOUR. I DON'T
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE IN
SUPPORT. BY IN. ONE TWENTY ONE.
MISTER MEMBERS JUST HIM ALONE
ON BEHALF OF THE COMPLEX
COALITION AND ALSO THE KING
PLEASE LOBBY COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. FIND.
ONE TWENTY SIX. JENNIFER
WILLIAMS WHAT THE EAST BAY
MUNICIPAL UTILITY DISTRICT AND
SUPPORT. BY NINETY SIX. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE BALKANS OFFICE ON
BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. ONE
ONE OH SEVEN. CAPTAIN DONE ON
THE HOUSE THE ALLIANCE OF
NURSES FOR HEALTHY AND HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENTS WE SUPPORT THANK
YOU. BY. NINETY EIGHT. BRENT
CENTER ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN
STITCHES NINE IN SUPPORT. NINE
ONE SIXTEEN. PAGE CHAIR MEMBERS
HAVE NAME LOCK ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTRE FOR FIXING THE PORT. ONE
ONE OH SIX. MARK RONSON AND
THEY HAVE THE RESOURCE RECOVERY
COALITION OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. ONE ONE TWENTY FOUR.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SHARON GREEN
WHAT THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SANITATION DISTRICT IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. NINE SIXTY FIVE.
PRESHOW THIS DEBBIE POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR IN SUPPORT. NINE
EIGHTY NINE. DANIEL GOOD CARE
OF ON BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. NINE SIXTY EIGHT. GOOD
MORNING CLINTON LACK ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
COALITION ADVOCACY IN SUPPORT.
IF WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE IS
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY NOW TO PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE
PHONE. WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
TWENTY NINE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
THIS IS JIM WEINBERG ON BEHALF
OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN Q. I SEE WE HAVE
A SOMEONE LIKE TO WIN HERE IN
PERSON. THANK YOU HELLO MY NAME
IS SUSAN LITTLE I'M WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP AND
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE FIVE
CO SPONSORS INFORMAL WORKING
GROUP BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS CLEAN WATER ACTION.
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN THIS CENTER FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AS WELL AS
THE SIXTY OTHER SUPPORTERS
WHICH MANY OF WHOM ALREADY
SPOKE BUT WHICH COMPRISE-
COMPANY IN INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATIONS PUBLIC AGENCY
ASSOCIATIONS ENVIRONMENTAL
NGOS. HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION ORGANIZATIONS
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS CONSUMER
COMMUNITY WOMEN'S AND
OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH GROUPS ALL
OF WHOM ARE RATED LISTED ON THE
ANALYSIS NOT REFER YOU TO THEM
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ARE THAT'S
CO TWO OPPOSITION AND WE HAVE
GOT DON KHAKI AND TIM JUST THE
DYNAMIC DUO TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION WAS ARE YOU DONE. OR
TAMMY THERE ON THE FRONT. OF
THE REAR I DONT CALCULATE MCCUE
KEPT CAN AFFECT AT THE MAP
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION- I WITH
CURRENTLY IN OPPOSE. POSITION
ON AB TWELVE HUNDRED I THANK
YOU DEARLY APPRECIATE THEM
UNDERTAKEN ARE BY THE AUTHOR
AND SPONSORS AS WELL AS THE ON
GOING CONVERSATIONS REGARDING A
COUPLE REMAINING ISSUES
MANUFACTURING COMMITTEE HOUSE
BUT THAT. BILL NAMELY THE
DEFINITION OF INTENTIONALLY
ADDED I THINK HEY LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING THE PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS ON THE ISSUE
SPECIFICALLY IN THE COMING
DAYS. IN ADDITION TO THE
DEFINITION AND PASHLEY ADDED
INTO A MEMBER COMPANIES OF ALL
THE RATE IF YOU INTENTIONALLY
ISSUES RELATED TO
IMPLEMENTATION TRANSFERRED THE
GIRLS WORKABLE AND FOCUSED ON
THE CONCERN AT HAND. FIRST WE
WOULD NOTE THAT THE INTENT
DEFINITION OF COOKWARE IN THE
BILL LACKS CLARITY OF SCOPE.
MORE SPECIFICALLY THE INCLUSION
OF A GRADE COOKWARE INCLUDES
BUT IS NOT LIMITED YOU. MAY
CREATE REGULATORY UNCERTAINTY
FOR MANUFACTURERS AND I THINK
WHETHER THEIR. PRODUCTS ARE
SUBJECT USE REQUIREMENT.
MEMBERS BUT- FOR THE CLEAR AND
THAT YOU'RE- SO THAT THE
MANUFACTURER COMMUNITY HAVE THE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE- BOB.
YOU'RE JUST REQUIREMENTS.
ADDITIONAL WE AGREE THEM OF
CHECKING FARTHER THE MATH
SEVEN. DISCLOSURE THAT SAID WE
WERE REASONABLE. OF THE BILL
CARDS WHAT WE'RE- COOKWARE.
CAME ON PRADA DISCLOSURE ONLINE
DISCLOSURE AND A Q. R. CODE OR
SOME FORM OF SCANNABLE CODE. IN
GADSDEN G. RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
FLEXIBILITY REGARDING THE
METHOD USED TO CONVEY
INGREDIENT INFORMATION. WHETHER
THAT BE ON THE LABEL VIA
MANUFACTURER WEBSITE OR Q. R.
CODE OR SOME SCANNABLE CODE. SO
AS NOT TO BE UNNECESSARILY
DUPLICATIVE AVOID INCREASED
PACKAGING AND LABELING WASTE
AND TO ADDRESS THE POTENTIAL
FOR MORE SPACE FOR THE REQUIRED
DISCLOSURE. ALL DECIDED WE
REALLY SINCERELY APPRECIATE THE
AUTHORED SPONSORS WILLINGNESS
TO WORK WITH HIM J. AND A
COLLEAGUE ORGANIZATIONS. TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE CONCERNS
WITH AB TWELVE HUNDRED I LOOK
FORWARD TO FURTHER DISCUSSIONS
REGARDING THE REMAINING
CONCERNS AND CERTAINLY IN THE
NEAR TERM SPECIFICALLY
REGARDING THE DEFINITION OF
INTENTIONALLY ADDED. THANK YOU.
THANK. YOU DIMAS CURTAIN
CHESTER. IF YOU ARE ALLEN
COMMITTEE AT THAT'S A GOOD
AMERICAN AND COUNCIL I DO THINK-
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE UP TO
TODAY I WILL GO. ALL OF THE
THAT THEY ARE THEY DON DID NOT
TO READ THE POINT YOU MAY BE
WEAKER ALSO HAVE A PROGRAM
AMENDED POSITION AND I DO WANT
TO EXPAND OUR THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BEING IN THE
STAFF AND THE BILL SPONSORED IN
THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH
THAT YOU WORK. ON THERE IS A
MAN THAT YOU ADDRESS. I THINK
OF IF IS DUE THE PROP. MISTER
RT. ON THAT THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENT TO THE DEFINITION OF
IT. ADDED IN. WE ARE CURRENTLY.
OUT LANGUAGE. BUT WE ARE STILL
TO BE. FROM OUR COALITION
PARTNERS- AND RESPECTED MEMBER
COMPANIES. WHICH APPEARS TO BE
MUCH MORE. THEY WHAT'S CURRENT
IN THE BILL ON I'M OPTIMISTIC
ABOUT RECEIVING FINAL FEEDBACK
I HEAR IN THE COMING DAYS. BUT
HE SAID THAT- YOU AGAIN WANT TO
THANK GOD IN RESPONSE TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH US.
WE ARE FIRMLY COMMITTED TO
WORKING TO RESOLVE. THE
REMAINING ISSUES AS THE BILL
MOVES. THROUGH THE SENATE THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
AT THAT SPOT. THREE THREE YOU.
I'M WE SOME OF WE'VE BEEN ABLE
OR AT LEAST SOME OF THE ISSUES
HAVE BEEN RAISED SO- THAT'S
GOOD OKAY LET'S GO ANYWHERE
ELSE WHEN A MODERATOR ANYONE
WANT TO BE ON ONE WAY IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION CONCERNS
WITH THE BILL ON THE PHONE
LINES. YOU'D LIKE TO WEIGH IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE WILL FIRST GO
TO LINE ONE TWENTY GO AHEAD
PLEASE. TWENTY CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ADAMANTLY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE ONE EYELINER COMMENTS
WITH THE C. M. D. N. A. T. T.
WE DO REALLY APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS-
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH US.
CALCHAMBER IS PREPARED TO MOVE
TO NEUTRAL BASED ON AMENDMENTS
THAT WE'VE DISCUSSED AND ARE
COMMITTED TO AGREEING TO
HOWEVER THOSE ARE IN PRINT YET
SO WE'RE RESERVING- OF OFFICIAL
CHANGE OF POSITION BUT JUST
WANT TO NOTE THAT- WE'RE
PRETTY. COMFORTABLE WITH WHAT
THE WHAT AMENDMENTS ARE BEING
PROPOSED SO JUST WANT TO MAKE
THAT ON RECORD THANK YOU BIJAN.
ANYONE ELSE BUT WHAT BLOOD ONE
TWENTY SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON OR
GOOD MORNING UP. SENATOR ALLEN
AND MEMBERS KATHY LAND.
AMERICAN FOREST AND PAPER
ASSOCIATION ALSO WANT TO ALIGN
WITH THE COMMENT. ABOUT HIM AND
DON THANK YOU. THANK YOU BYE IN.
SIXTY THREE. THANK GOD JOHN
CAN'T CREATION OF HOME
APPLIANCE MANUFACTURERS AND WE
ARE OPPOSE THANK YOU. IF THERE
ARE ANY OTHER VOICES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. SURE WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE CUED UP. OUR LET'S
BRING THE ITEM TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR DISCUSSIONS AND ALI. YEAH I
JUST WANTED COMMENTED. IT SEEMS
WE HAVE A THEME TODAY OF. BILLS
THAT ARE COMING THROUGH WEEK SO
I JUST WANTED TO SPEND.
GENERALLY STATE WE'VE WE HAVE
THE DEPARTMENT TOXIC SUBSTANCE
WHICH WE WORKED ON IT MEANS IS
THAT- I CAL SKIN I SAID ON. SUB
TWO AND WE'RE FINDING THEM AND
WE'RE GIVING THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. MOVE THROUGH
THESE PROCESSES WHERE WE HAVE-
YOU KNOW SCIENCE AND DATA AND
THINGS THAT WE CAN TRY TO GET
TO A PLACE WHERE. THE
MANUFACTURERS KNOW WHAT THE
RULES ARE AND SO TODAY WE'VE
SEEN TWO BILLS NOW- COMING
THROUGH WITH. YOU KNOW SPEEDING
UP THE PROCESS ARE NEARING IN
ON. ON CERTAIN PRODUCTS AND SO
I'M A LITTLE AREAS OF THE FACT
THAT IN AND WE'VE HEARD FROM
THE OPPOSITION THAT. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. BE HELD
HARMLESS I THINK IS SOMETHING
THAT THEY THEY NEED TO BE ABLE
TO NOT BE ABLE TO GO SU IF WERE.
CHANGING THAT WERE FOR SPEEDING
UP THE PROCESS QUITE FRANKLY SO
I'M AND I KNOW THAT BOTH
AUTHORS THAT CAME IN HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION TO
TRY TO GET. TO A PLACE WHERE
EVERYBODY IS WORKABLE SO I JUST
WANT TO SHARE THAT I THINK THAT
WE DO. A AND FOR THE FOR THE
TIME I'VE SAT ON THIS COMMITTEE
IN THIS HOUSE IN THE TIME I SAT
ON THE COMMITTEE IN THE OTHER
HOUSE E. Q. WE'VE BEEN. VERY
CRITICAL OF DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES AND HOW. AND GREEN
CHEMISTRY ON HOW WE GET. FROM
WHERE WERE ARE TO WHERE WE WERE.
WANT TO GO. TO WANT TO SURE
THAT WE'RE- AS SENIOR LOT OF
BILLS THROUGH SO I. COMMTTEE
THE AUTHOR I MEAN OF. LAY OFF
YOUR BILL UNTIL I SEE WHAT THE
MIMICS REAL ARE BUT I DON'T
ONCE WE ENCOURAGE- THE
COMMITTEE. MAKE SURE THAT THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE TRYING TO. GET
TO A PLACE WHERE THEIR
MANUFACTURING IN MAKING IT SAFE
FOR THE PUBLIC THAT THEY HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET CAUGHT IN
A CATCH TWENTY TWO BECAUSE
WE'RE MOVING A LITTLE BIT. FOR
TRYING TO PUSHED. DEPARTMENT
TALK TO SUBJECTS. SUBSTANCE
INTO. IT TO GET THESE DONE SO I
JUST CAUTION AND WE'VE- WE'VE
DIPPED. IN THIS BUDGET. HAS
BEEN PROPOSED A LOT OF
RESOURCES TO HELP. DEPARTMENT
TOXIC SUBSTANCE GET WHERE THEY
NEED TO BE IN SO I THINK WE'RE
PUSHING THEM. WITHOUT GIVING
THEM THE OPPORTUNITY. WITH THE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE. TO GET
WHERE WE WANT TO GO SO JUST A
COMMENT I KNOW THAT THE- THE
BOTH AUTHORS APPEAR LOOK NOBODY
WANTS THESE. THIS STUFF IN
THEIR PRODUCTS AND YOU'VE HEARD
FROM THE MANUFACTURER SO JUST-
ENCOURAGEMENT TO BE ABLE TO
GETS TO. HAVE A- PLACE WHERE
THE- OPPOSITION IS COMFORTABLE
AS WELL AND ARE NOT. HELD TO
SOME. THE STANDARD THAT ALLOWS
THEM TO BE SUED AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT I AM SOME OF OUR-
AT LEAST ON THE REPUBLICAN SIDE
HERE. COMMENTS HAVE BEEN YOU
KNOW THE LIABILITY PART OF IT
IS A BIG DEAL. AND WE STILL
NEED THESE WE STILL NEED THESE
PRODUCTS BILL TO PACKAGE OUR
FOOD AND GET IT WE'RE GOING TO
ESPECIALLY. WITH TAKE OUT IN
THE THINGS WE'VE SEEN DURING
THE PANDEMIC SO JUST SOME
THOUGHTS THANK YOU. SARCASTIC
IS THE AUTHOR KNOWS I'VE BEEN A
DEFENDER GREEN CHEMISTRY IN
VERY LEERY OF ONE OFFS I THINK
WHAT IS DIFFERENT IN THIS
SITUATION AND I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BEAVER IS THAT
FOOD DGSE HAS ALREADY
IDENTIFIED AS TO PRIORITY-
PRODUCTS WITH ED HAPPY FAST
WITH CARPETS AND A PLANT BASED
FOOD SO WE'RE TAKING A SEPARATE
SEIZE THE LEGISLATURE'S WE'VE
GOT THAT BOOK SLOW MOVING THE
MINUTE LEAVE CRITICAL SLOW
MOVING- TRAIN THAT IS
IDENTIFIED PLANT FACE COVERING
SO BY EXTENDING IT TO. ALL FOOD
PACKAGING IT'S IN THIS IT I
THINK IT'S HARMONIZING RIGHT
AND OBVIOUSLY TO MOVE TO COOK
WHERE HE HAD TO BE AND THE
CHAPLAIN PAN BEFORE YOU GOT
INTO THE IF THE FOOD PACKAGING
SO IT'S NOT IN THE IN THE RICH
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE TRADITION
OF ONE OFF CHEMICAL BANDS TO
COME OUT OF NOWHERE THAT ARE
ARE ADVOCATES GIVE IS TO SELL
AT WITH THAT SAID AND- VARYING
NARROWLY. TAILORED I WOULD MOVE
THE BILL. THANK YOU. THE HAS
BEEN MOVED WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE FIFTIES VERY QUICKLY IN
THE SENATE SENATOR DOLLY AND I
ARE FROM THE SAME CLASS WEEKLY
CAME INTO OFFICE IN TWENTY
TWELVE WEEKS SAT ON THE STM
TOGETHER FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
AND WE CONSTANTLY HEARD OF THE
INDUSTRY TALKING ABOUT WAIT FOR
THE GREEN CHEMISTRY PROCESS
WAIT FOR THE GREEN CHEMISTRY
PROCESS I THINK CENTER CAL SKI.
COMMENTED AS TO HOW THEY'VE
IDENTIFIED- THESE PRODUCTS
ALREADY- HOWEVER WERE LONGER
FRESHMEN OR IN OUR SECOND TERM
FOR OUR THIRD TERM THIS HAS
BEEN WE WE'VE BEEN IN OFFICE
NOW FOR NINE YEARS ON AND THE
PROCESS HAS MOVED TOO SLOWLY TO
THE POINT WHERE AGAIN. INDUSTRY
IS ALREADY MOVING AHEAD OF THIS
PROCESS YOU HAVE MAKE DONALD
YOU HAVE. THE TRIPLE A YOU HAVE
WHOLE FOODS YOU HAVE WENDY'S
THESE ARE NOT SMALL COMPANY
WITH ALL OF THE LOAN MOVES THE
MARKET AS WE ALL KNOW. IT SO IF
THEY'RE SAYING THIS IS
SOMETHING A PRODUCT OR WE DON'T
FEEL COMFORTABLE GIVING TO OUR
CONSUMERS I THINK IT'S
CALIFORNIANS WE HAVE TO TAKE A
VERY LEERY- LOOK AT THESE
CHEMICALS AND POTENTIALLY THE
DATA THAT THE DATA IS THE DATA
IS THERE. THE SCIENCE IS THERE
I THINK IT WAS TIME FOR US TO
ACT SO WITHOUT REALLY
APPRECIATE THE MOTION AND DO
ASK FOR YOUR ABOUT. TO ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR A BI TWELVE
HUNDRED THANK YOU. CONSERVATOR
THE ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWELVE
HUNDRED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TANG
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED ALAN HI ALAN I'D BATES.
IT'S NOT VOTING DALLY. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ HI SKINNER STERN BY
CAL SKI BY ASKING FIVE. MMHM.
NO. OKAY TIME THAT THE
RESIDENTS WITH ITS THREE TWELVE
THAT'S ARE YES WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON
THE LIST ONCE YOU GO INTO A B.
TWELVE A ONE AB TROUBLE ONE
REQUIRES PRODUCTS TO MEET
HIGHER QUALITY STANDARDS IN
ORDER TO BE LABELED AS
COMPOSTABLE- REQUIRES THAT
PRODUCTS ARE LABELED. AS
COMPOSTABLE HOME COMPOSTABLE TO
MEET. INTERNATIONAL AS WELL AS
STATE STANDARDS THAT WILL BE
CERTIFIED BY A THIRD PARTY.
CERTIFICATION PROCESS- THE BILL
PRESENT PREVENTS PRODUCTS WITH
INTENTIONALLY ADDED P. FAST
FROM BEING LABELED AS COUPLES
BECAUSE IT WOULD CONTAMINATE.
THE COMPASS STREAM AND END UP
IN OUR FOOD CHAIN. LASTLY OUR
BILL REQUIRES COMPOSTABLE
PRODUCTS BE CLEARLY LABEL TO
ENGLISH EVE EASILY DISTINGUISH
BETWEEN PRODUCTS ARE
COMPOSTABLE AND NON.
COMPOSTABLE ARE WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPOSITION'S
COMMENTED WE CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THEM I HAVE NEIL EDGAR
FROM THE CALIFORNIA COMPOST
COALITIONS BOTH NICK LAPLACE
LAPIS- FROM THE CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE. ALL RIGHT LET'S
START WITH YOU- IF. THE MORNING
CARE ELENA MEMBERS I'M AT YOUR
DIRECTOR IN CALIFORNIA
COALITION OUR MEMBERS ARE
PREDOMINATELY SERVICE PROVIDERS
MUNICIPALITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WHO PROCESS YARD
TRIMMINGS AND INCREASINGLY
COULD WEIGH. THE VAST MAJORITY
WELL OVER 95% OF PROPOSAL
PACKAGING IS CURRENTLY BEING
LANDFILLED. AB TWELVE A ONE OF
THE NECESSARY STAFF MAKING
COMPOSTABLE PRODUCTS PART OF
THE SUCCESSFUL ORGANIC
RECYCLING THEM AND KEEP THEM
OUT OF LANDFILLS. AB TWELVE OH
ONE COMES AT A CRITICAL TIME IN
HELPING TO ENSURE THAT COMPOSED
LOCAL PACKAGING FEATURED VALUE
PROMISE AS AN ASSET TO BOTH
SCRAP RECYCLING PROGRAM.
HELPING COMPOSTERS CLOSE THE
LOOP ON ORGANIC MATERIAL AND
HELP THE STATE NEEDED CLIMATE
CHANGE GOALS INSTEAD OF BURNING
ARE ALREADY INFRASTRUCTURE WITH
CONTAMINATION JOHNSON. THE
DALLAS LABELLING IDENTIFICATION
BANNERED THE GOING TO THE
COLORING AND IDENTIFICATION
MARKING FOR COMPOSABLE
PACKAGING WILL HELP PREVENT
CONSUMER CONFUSION ONE STAR
SEPARATING FOOD WASTE. AND
ENHANCE THE ABILITY OF
PROCESSING FACILITY OPERATORS
TO REMOVE NON COMPOSTABLE
PACKAGING HELPING REDUCE
CONTAMINATION ADVENT CAP
COLLECTION PROGRAM. AND CRITICS
CLAIM TOP THE- IN PROGRAMS FOR
THE UNITS PAL THE AND RAY. WE.
AT IS THE A LARGE MARKET FOR
COMBAT WITH OVER SIXTY PER
SHARE NOW. AND THE REMAINING
LARGE UNTAPPED. ACT DIVERSE
PROGRAM GRABBED MEDICAL OVER
THE SEVERAL YEARS THE NEED A
LOT TO GO OF THE F. B. A THREE.
IMPORTANT PROVIDING CLEAN OR
GET COMPOST AGRIC MY- WILL
INCREASE DEMAND. I'M
MANUFACTURER FACILITY SHOULD
NOT THERE IS A PROXY FOR
LANDFILL THE FOURTH STEP
WHATEVER PRODUCT MANUFACTURERS
WHICH THE CALL COMPOSABLE. THIS
IS NOT A CIRCULAR SOLUTION FOR
THOSE PRODUCTS WHICH DO NOT
MEET THE REQUIREMENTS OF THIS
BILL AND WILL FURTHER
PERPETUATE GREEN WATCHING WHICH
IS A STARKLY CONTRACEPTIVE
CONTAMINATION AND I'M
REASONABLE CAUGHT THE COMPOST
PRODUCERS. WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE R.
ONE AND THAT'S WHAT I LOVE.
THANK YOU MUNIS CLINIC LAPIS. I
COULD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS NICK OPPOSITE
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE.
NEIL EDGAR COVERED MOST OF THE
DETAILS SO I WILL BE BRIEF IN
MY COMMENTS. THIS ACTUALLY
FAIRLY SIMPLE BILL THAT ENSURES
THAT CONSUMERS GET WHAT THEY
PAY FOR WHEN THEY BUY A PRODUCT
THAT'S LABELED COMPOSTABLE.
MYERS AT THE PRODUCT IS THIRD
PARTY CERTIFIED ACTUALLY BREAK
DOWN IN CALIFORNIA COMPOSTING
FACILITIES- IT'S REQUIRED NOT
CONTAMINATE COMPOST OR THE
STATE AGRICULTURAL SYSTEM WITH
TOXIC CHEMICALS LIKE PEACOCKS.
AND IT IS READILY IDENTIFIABLE
TO BOTH CONSUMERS AND SOLID
WASTE FACILITIES AND
DESTRUCTIVE LOOKALIKE PRODUCTS
AREN'T ALLOWED TO GREENWASHING
THEIR PRODUCTS AND COMPETE WITH
GENUINELY COMPOSTABLE
ALTERNATIVES- IN ADDITION TO
WHAT NIELSEN I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE OVERLAP BETWEEN
THIS BILL AND TWO OTHER BILLS
THAT HAVE COME BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE. THIS YEAR- THE FIRST
WITH THE CHAIRS SB THREE FORTY
THREE THAT ENACTED PARALLEL
LIMITS ON THE ITEMS LABELED
RECYCLABLE. AND THE SECOND IS A
FAMILY MEMBER GONZALEZ IS AB
EIGHT EIGHT ONE OF THE
COMMITTEE BACK I'M SO SORRY WE
HAVE TO ASK YOU TO FINISH UP.
OKAY MY ABOUT FINAL STATEMENT
SORRY- IS THAT TOGETHER THESE
THREE BILLS SHOULD RESTORE
CONSUMERS SAY THAN THE
RECYCLING SYSTEM BY ENSURING
THAT THINGS LABELED RECYCLABLE
OR COMPOSTABLE ARE TRULY
RECYCLABLE OR COMPOSTABLE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND ACTUALLY GET
RECYCLED OR COMPOSTED IF THE
CONSUMER DOES THEIR JOB B
PUTTING HIM IN THE RIGHT AND
ZACHARY. YEP OKAY THANK YOU-
LET'S GO TO THE PHONE LINES
EVEN WANTS TO WAIT IN SUPPORT.
HE WOULD LIKE TO WIN IN SUPPORT
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE SEVENTY
ONE GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON DANIEL BROADCASTS
CARE CLUB CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT GIVE. NINE SIXTY EIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CLINTON LOOK
BACK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION ADVOCACY
AND SUPPORT. BY. NINETY SIX.
LINE NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE BALKANS OFFICE ON
BEHALF OF BIRD TACK IN THE CITY
OF THOUSAND OAKS AND SUPPORT.
FIND. ONE HUNDRED ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS A LEASE
CONTRACTS THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE
OF CONSERVATION VOTERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. LINE ONE OH SIX
JUST- MARC FERRANTI ON BEHALF
OF THE RESOURCE RECOVERY
COALITION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. NINE ONE OH SEVEN.
AFTER DODD THE ALLIANCE NURSES
FOR HEALTHY ENVIRONMENTS IN
SUPPORT. NINE ONE TWENTY ONE.
CUSTOMER NUMBER HOPE TO THE
CLEAN SEAS LOBBY COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. NINE ONE TWENTY
TWO. THANK YOU YOUR NUMBER'S
NIKITA KARATE WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE ONE
TWENTY FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON
BRIDGET MCHALE ME HALF OF
BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS IN SUPPORT OF THE
REGISTER IN SUPPORT FOR CLEAN
WATER ACTION THANK YOU. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER SUPPORT
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE. ONE
TWENTY EIGHT. NOONE CANNOT
BRING IT ON ON BEHALF OF STOP
WAIT CALIFORNIA PRODUCTS GET
YOU CAN'T FALL AND THE NATIONAL
ACTION COUNCIL AND THE COURT
THANK YOUNG. MR HERE WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. LET'S GO TO READ
OPPOSITION WITH A STOMP TECHIE-
SERVICING CMT. GREAT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS ON
CAPTAINING THE Q. CAPTAIN
ADVOCATES ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION CURRENTLY WITH AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON IT A LITTLE TROUBLE ONE. WE
DO APPRECIATE HOWEVER THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS WILLINGNESS
TO CONTINUE THE DIALOGUE ON THE
BILL LAST YEAR REVISED GREATER
CLARITY ODD AND YOU ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CONCERNS ARE THAT
GMG MEMBER COMPANIES HAVE
IDENTIFIED FIVE. OUT OF THE
GATE TO BE CLEAR SKIN J. AND
MEMBER COMPANIES DO SUPPORT
ESTABLISHING CLEAR STANDARDS
FOR GREEN CLAIMS SUCH AS
COMPOSTABLE TO ENSURE CLARITY
FOR CONSUMERS AND TO CREATE A
LEVEL PLAYING FIELD FOR
MANUFACTURERS THAT WISH TO
INVEST IN COMBUSTIBLE PRODUCTS
AND PACKAGING THAT SAID WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT AB TROUBLE ONE
OF CURRENTLY DROPPED DEAD WOULD
PROHIBIT LEGITIMATE COMPOSABLE
CLEAN ON A VARIETY OF PRODUCTS
AND PACKAGING. THEREBY CREATING
A DISINCENTIVE FOR
MANUFACTURERS AND COMBUSTIBLE
MATERIALS ARE FUNDAMENTAL
CONCERN WITH AB TROUBLE ONE OF
CURRENTLY DROPPED IS THAT IT
WOULD REQUIRE A PRODUCT LABELED
AS COMPOSED OF ALL TO BE AN
ALLOWABLE ORGANIC AND PLANT I'M
THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE
NATIONAL ORGANIC PROGRAM. AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE'S ORGANIC AND
NATURAL PROGRAM UNFORTUNATELY
HOWEVER THE NOPD AND ORGANIC
MATERIAL PROGRAMMER. OKAY JOHN.
PRODUCT PACKAGING APPROACH
COULD FOR ORGANIC I. PRODUCTS
TO FIVE AND CROP. IN THIS
REGARD ANY. OR PACKAGE THAT CAN
BE LABELED AS OF TODAY. BUT
THAT MADE BY YOU PATTERSON FOR
AND GOT CON FOR OTHER USE. WITH
NO BE ABLE TO DELAY COMPOSTABLE
THAT WOULD NOT BE DEEMED ACROSS
FOR THE NEAR SCOPE THE BILL OF
ORGANIC ON. SPONSOR OF AB
TWELVE AWAY. SEVEN AT THE
INDIAN NUMBER COMPANIES THE
BIGGEST MARKET GOING DRUG. OUT
I DID ORGANIC AGRO. AND
INTEREST. ACTUALLY DROPPED A
WITH YOUR MARKETING. BUT THE
PRO DOESN'T RECOGNIZE THE BY OF
SEVERAL OTHER HARD EARNED
DOCTORAL CALL. THE FIRE. OF ALL
THE EQUIPMENT SHOULD APPROACH
ORGANIC FARMING SUCH AS GOING.
AND ARE CONTROL. IN FACT ON
INNOVATION FOR COMPANIES
SEEKING TO USE MORE SUSTAINABLE
PRODUCTS AND PACKAGING AMID A
LARGER PUSH RELATED TO THE
CIRCULAR ECONOMY AND THE
STATE'S WASTE REDUCTION GOAL.
ORDINIS CM JANET MEMBER
COMPANIES BELIEVE THAT THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS UNDERLYING
TENTH MAY BE ACHIEVED BY
NARROWING THE SCOPE OF THE BILL
THE PRODUCTS THAT ARE INTENDED
TO FALL WITHIN THE WITHIN THE
SCOPE OF NOPD MAINLY
ORGANICALLY PRODUCED
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS. FOOD
FIGHT FRENCH TO CROP. FINALLY
THINKING OF MEMBER COMPANIES
ARE ALSO CONSTRUED THE NEW
LABELING REQUIREMENTS UNDER
EACH OTHER ONE WHAT WE SUPPORT
CLEAR COMMUNICATION OF CLAIMS.
TO CONSUMERS THAT COMPOSTABLE
CROP. I'M THE OKAY. ALL RIGHT
WELL THANK YOU DONNA YOU YOU
HAVE REACHED YOUR TIMES BUT-
BUT BUT HOPEFULLY IT WILL STAY
ON IN CASES ANY QUESTIONS OTHER
PEOPLE MY ONE ASK LET'S GO TO-
THE PHONE LINES IF ANYONE ELSE
WANTS TO RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE BILL. OR THE OPPOSITION
MODERATOR. IF THERE IS
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. BUT
AGAIN PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
STRUCTURE WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUING
UP AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU SO THE BILLS BEFORE THE
MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS. OUR MOTION. THE MOVE
BY A CENTER GONZALEZ AND I. SEE
NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
YOU MAY CLOSE. THAT THEY CAN TO
CHAIR JUST VERY BRIEFLY A
COUPLE TO SOMETHING THAT'S
REALLY WONDERFUL ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES IS WHEN YOU PUT- P.
FAST CONTAMINATED- BURKE LIKE
LIKE FOOD YOU KNOW- FAST FOOD
WRAPPINGS OR- ANY KIND OF FIVE
BAGS OR EVEN RECEIPTS I I'VE
TALKED ABOUT PAPER RECEIPTS THE
PAST. THE CONTAMINATES THE
COMPOST DREAM UNNECESSARILY WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT FOR
PROJECT IS ACTUALLY COMPOSTABLE
DOESN'T CONTAIN P. FAST- WHICH
I THINK WILL CAP THE MAKE THE
COMPOST THE MOST VALUABLE.
PRODUCT IT COULD BE SO WITHOUT
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL YES
OKAY THANK YOU AND WE WILL AND
WE DO CONTINUE TO BE AWARE OF
AND WE WANT TO WORK WITH THE-
THE WITH WITH DON AND HER FOLKS
TO MAKE SURE THAT. NOTHING AND
THAT THAT THE WE'RE NOT GONNA
HARM INDUSTRIAL COMPOSTING AS
PART OF THIS PROCESS WHICH
ROUGHLY RIGHT THERE AND YOU'RE
GETTING IT AT A REAL ISSUE HERE
WHICH IS THAT FOR THE VAST
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE- THE ITEMS
THAT THEY BY THINKING THAT
THEIR COMBUSTIBLE ARE ACTUALLY
NOT COMBUSTIBLE AND SO WE'RE
GETTING SOME TRUTH IN
ADVERTISING HERE. SO FOLKS ARE
ARE BETTER INFORMED- WITH THAT
THE MOVE I SENATORS ALWAYS
CONSULT PLEASE COLOR. I NUMBER
SO. A. TWELVE A ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TANG THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. ALLEN HI ALLEN
AYE BATES. IT'S NOT VOTING
TALLY GONZALEZ GONZALEZ ICE
SKINNER STERN ALL RIGHT STERN
AYE WHY CASKEY HI ASKI I'D NINE
THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR SENATE SKINNER TO
ADD ON THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OKAY LET'S ASK- ASSEMBLY
GONZALES TO COME TO THE- TO THE
DíAS- SHE'S HERE PRESENTING AB
SEVENTY FOUR THIS IS WENDY
CARILLO SPELL AB SEVEN NINETY
FOUR ITEMS THREE AND YOUR
AGENDAS. MEMBERS MAY PERCEIVE
AND READY TO CELEBRATE WITH BY
THE WAY I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT
WE HAVE- HAS SOME LATE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE'VE WORKED
OUT- THE WITH THE AUTHOR- IT'S
RESOLVED AT LEAST SOME OF THE
SIGNIFICANT OPPOSITION CONCERNS
AND I THINK EVERYBODY'S BEEN
PROVIDED WITH A COPY IF YOU
DON'T HAVE A COPY THOSE MOMENTS
PLEASE LET LET US KNOW WE'LL
GET YOU COPY. 30% CARE IN
MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING TO PRESENT
AB SEVEN NINETY FOUR AND A HALF
ASSEMBLY WOMAN CREE- AS YOU
STATED I BELIEVE- STRIKING THE
INTENT LANGUAGE HAS HELPED
REMOVE AGAIN. THE OPPOSITION
HOPEFULLY FINALLY THIS TIME AND
NOT ASKING FOR STRIKING MORE
THINGS. IN THE BILL. MOVE THE
BILL AB. THANK YOU. I'D LIKE TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE MEMANTINE
THANK ME STAFF ON BEHALF OF THE
AUTHOR FOR THE WORK ON THESE.
AB SEVEN NINETY FOUR WOULD
REQUIRE PUBLIC SUBSIDIES FOR
CLEAN DREDGING SHORT HAUL
TRUCKS TO BE TIED COMPLIANCE
WITH LABOR STANDARDS. AS
IMPORTANT AS IT IS FOR STATE TO
TRANSITION TO A GREEN ECONOMY
IT'S EQUALLY IMPORTANT MAKE
SURE WE PROTECT AND SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA WORKERS.ABILITY TO
STATE TO MEET AMBITIOUS CLIMATE
GOALS DEPENDS IN LARGE PART ON
FLEET PURCHASERS TRANSITIONING
TO ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES. AS
WE WORK TO COMBAT. GREEN GET
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS FROM
THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR IT'S
IMPORTANT REALIZE THERE'S A
HISTORY OF LABOR LAW VIOLATIONS
IN THE COMMERCIAL TRUCKING
INDUSTRY. CAN IN THE DROEGE
INDUSTRY IN PARTICULAR TRACKING
COMPANIES INTENTIONALLY AND
ILLEGALLY MISCLASSIFIED DRIVERS
AS INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS TO
SHIFT THE COST OF DOING
BUSINESS. AS MENTIONED ANALYSIS
BETWEEN 75285% PORT TRUCK
DRIVERS LIKELY MEET THE CORPUS
CLASSIFICATION CRITERIA.
DRIVER'S CANNOT AFFORD THE NEW
CLEAN ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS WITH
THE COST TO PURCHASE MAINTAIN
VEHICLES FALLS ON THEM RATHER
THAN THE COMPANIES. AB SEVEN
NAME FOR WILL ENSURE THE PUBLIC
FUNDS ADMINISTERED BY CARD FOR
THE PURCHASE OF ZERO EMISSION
PORT DRAYAGE AND SHORT HAUL
TRUCKS ARE TIED TO REQUIREMENTS
OF THE FLEET PURCHASERS. NOT
VIOLATE STATE LAWS REGARDING
MISS CLASSIFICATION WORKERS IN
A BANK CONTRACTORS. I ADD. I
HOPE THAT THIS IS THE- IT WHAT
WITH A NUMBER OF OTHER BILLS
COMING THROUGH THAT THIS IS A
REAL- EFFORT TO LOOK FOR A JUST
TRANSITION AS WE'RE ALWAYS
TALKING ABOUT. HOW DO WE-
INCORPORATE THE NEEDS THAT WE
HAVE TO COMBAT CLIMATE CHANGE
ALONG WITH THE NEEDS TO ENSURE
THAT WORKERS ARE MADE WHOLE.
AND CONTINUE TO BE ABLE TO
PROSPER IN INDUSTRIES THAT ARE
PRIMARILY BLUE COLLAR IN THE
STATE I RESPECTFULLY ON BEHALF
OF THE AUTHOR ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE BEFORE THAT IN- FOR
TESTIMONY OF THEIR FLOCKS TO
REPRESENT TEAMSTERS PORT
DIVISION. AND SAM APPEL THE
CALIFORNIA POLICY MANAGER THE
GREEN. THE BLUE GREEN ALLIANCE.
SURGERIES ARE YOU SIR. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS THEIR FLOCKS- THE
TEAMSTERS PORT DIVISION WHERE A
CO SPONSOR OF THE BILL AND
WE'RE VERY PROUD TO BE PART OF
THIS COALITION IS A COALITION
OF LABOR COMMUNITY. AND
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS AND WE'VE
BEEN BROUGHT TOGETHER BY THE
BELIEF THAT WE CAN CREATE AND
WE NEED TO CREATE GOOD WELL
PAYING JOBS. IN ORDER TO MEET
OUR CLIMATE GOALS THAT CLIMATE
JUSTICE IS TIED TO ECONOMIC AND
TO RACIAL JUSTICE. LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ARE THE
HARDEST HIT BY CLIMATE CHANGE
AND THEY SUFFER A DIST
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF THE
IMPACTS. NO WHERE IS THAT MORE
CLEAR THAN AT THE PORTS AND IN
TRANSPORTATION. YOU SEE SHORT
HAUL AND DRAYAGE TRUCKS THE
HEAVIEST EMITTERS THESE ARE
HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS THEY'RE
MOVING GOODS FROM THE PORTS
THEY PUT THEM ON LONG HAUL
TRUCKS THOSE TRACKS GO ACROSS
ALL THE FREEWAYS. THEY GO TO
WAREHOUSES THERE IDOLING THERE
A MEETING MORE AND MORE TOXINS
AND ALL THE WHILE THESE ARE
pIMPORTS THEY'RE ALL UNDER THE
FREEWAYS AROUND WAREHOUSES
WORKERS AND COMMUNITIES ARE
SUFFERING. AND TRUCK DRIVERS AT
THE PORTS ARE ALSO SUFFERING
FROM MISS CLASSIFICATION. THEY
ARE JUST NOT MAKING THE WAGES
THAT THEY NEED TO BE ABLETO BE
PART OF THE TRANSITION. YOU CAN
SEE FROM THE AT THE ANALYSIS
WHICH WAS AN EXCELLENT
ANALYSIS- THAT- MISCLASSIFIED
OR INDEPENDENT CONTRACTED TRUCK
DRIVERS MAKE SIGNIFICANTLY LESS
THAN THOSE THAT ARE DIRECTLY
EMPLOYED. AND SO AT THE SAME
TIME THEY HAVE HIGHER CAPITAL
EXPENSES TO DO UPKEEP AND BUY
FUEL FOR THEIR TRUCKS. AND SO
MISCLASSIFIED TRUCK DRIVERS ARE
THE LEAST ABLE TO AFFORD THE
TRANSITION TO A CLEAN VEHICLES
AND YET THE STATE EXPECTS THEM
TO. THEY'RE THE ONES THAT HAVE
TO BEAR THE BURDEN OF THE
TRANSITION SO WHAT AB SEVEN
NINETY FOUR SIMPLY DOES IS IT
SAYS. THAT IN ORDER TO BE ABLE
TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR A CLEAN
VEHICLE SUBSIDY THROUGH CARB. A
TRUCKING COMPANY OR AN
INDEPENDENT TRUCKER HAS TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT THEY ARE IN
COMPLETE COMPLIANCE WITH THE
LAW THAT THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
VIOLATIONS RELATING TO- LAWS
THAT ARE DEAL WITH MISS
CLASSIFICATION. AND WE TOOK
AMENDMENTS IN THE ASSEMBLY TO
BE VERY CLEAR THAT THIS MEANS A
FINAL UNSATISFIED JUDGMENT
PASSED THE POINT OF APPEAL-
THAT THIS ISN'T GOING TO BE
SOMETHING FRIVOLOUS THAT WE
REALLY WANT. TO CREATE AN
INCENTIVE TO HAVE COMPANIES
TRANSITION TO AN EMPLOYMENT
MODEL TO BE IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THE LAW AND AT THE SAME TIME BE
IN COMPLIANCE WITH OUR CLIMATE
GOALS. SO WE THINK THAT SB
SEVEN NINETY FOUR IS AN
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP WE DO NEED
TO DO MORE TO CREATE GOOD JOBS
IN THE CLIMATIC ECONOMY
INCLUDING IN MANUFACTURING- BUT
WE WANTED TO START WITH THIS
VERY TARGETED- BILL IN ONE OF
THAT THE HIGHEST PRODUCING
INDUSTRIES AND SO WE URGE AYE.
THANK YOU AND I'M ALSO HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. DECIRME
ARE PROTECTED FROM SAM FELL
FROM BLUEGREEN ALLIANCE ON THE
FUNDS. AND THEN I WILL SAY SAM
AND SARAH VERY ELOQUENTLY TOOK
UP ALMOST ALL THE TIME SO
PLEASE KEEP A VERY BRIEF. YEAH
SHE DID A GREAT JOB. HE WAS%
GREAT THOUGH- GOOD MORNING
CHAIR ALLEN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MANY OF THEM WELL IN
THE STATE MANAGER FOR BLUE
GREEN ALLIANCE- WE'RE ALIGNED
WITH TEN LABOR UNIONS AND FIVE
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS. THE
TEAMSTERS AND AUTO WORKERS ARE
AMONG THE UNIONS THAT ANKARA
COALITION IN CALIFORNIA. IT'S
VERSION BUT THE BILL INCLUDED A
ROBOT MANUFACTURING
ARCHITECTURE- AND DUE TO
INDUSTRY OPPOSITION THOSE
PROVISIONS WERE REMOVED IN THE
ASSEMBLY CONNOR WAITED THE
SENATE WE RETAINED INTENT
LANGUAGE WHICH IS THIRD IN
CALIFORNIA'S INTENTIONS AT THE
CORE U. S. IN CALIFORNIA.
VEHICLE MANUFACTURING AND
HIGHER JOBS FOR DISADVANTAGED
WORKERS IN THE AUTO INDUSTRY
HAS CONTINUED TO OPPOSE THE
CONTENT WITH THE COALITION OF
DECIDED TO REMOVE THAT LANGUAGE
TO PROTECT ESSENTIAL TRACKING
ELEMENT THE BILL. WE WILL
CONTINUE TO TRACK FEDERAL
DISCUSSIONS AROUND THE AUTO
INDUSTRY- HOWEVER RIGHT NOW THE
EVEN CHINA ARE TAKING THE LEAD
IN GLOBAL YOU GAME BATTERY
PRODUCTION. MAJOR AUTOMAKERS
ARE OFFSHORING AUTO PRODUCTION
LINES INTO JOBS TO LOW WAGE
REGIONS OF THE WORLD. JEFF THAT
MIDDLE CLASS JOB MENTION AUTO
PRODUCTION AND OIL AND GAS
BEGIN TO DISAPPEAR. OUR LABOR
MARKET ASK YOU. TO WRAP IT UP.
ALL AGREE THAT WE NEED TO-
BUILD JOBS BACK THE UNITED
STATES AND EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY
FOUR MAIN TO PIVOT ON THE BENCH
OF THE ON THE TRUCKING DIED WE
URGE YOUR AYE THOSE. AND LOOK
FORWARD TO FUTURE DISCUSSION
WITH YOU ON THE TOPIC. THANK
YOU SAM ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE
GONNA TAKE A- FO'C'SLE
MODERATOR ANYONE WANTS TO WEIGH
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL SEVENTY
FOUR. ON THE PHONES. AT THE
VOICE YOUR SUPPORT PRESS ONE
THE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL GO
FIRST TO LINE ONE OH FIVE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BERS MITCH SNIDER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO EXPORT. ONE ONE THIRTY
FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS PATAKI DOC ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION IMPORT THANK YOU.
NINE ONE TEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COUNCIL CO SPONSOR THE
BILL AND- OUR- LINE. SEVENTY
ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL
BROUGHT IN THE APPS CARE QUITE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TO FIND ONE FIFTEEN. THAT
AFTERNOON THIS IS A BARRAGE OF
BULLETS JOBS WITH AMERICA AND
WE ARE PROBABLY IN PART. NINE
SIXTY FIVE. NINE SIXTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. TOM KRISHER OTHERS WITH
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR IN
SUPPORT. PINE. ONE THIRTEEN.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
I'M GOING TO BE ON BEHALF OF
THE UNITED AUTO WORKERS REGION
EIGHT AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NINE SIXTY FOUR. INSTEAD OF THE
SAINTS WITH PLANE IN THE LAND
ECONOMY AND SUPPORT. NINE ONE
ZERO ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON ONLY
CONTACT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. LINE
ONE NINETEEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AARON
RODRIGUEZ UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. LINE. ONE EIGHTEEN. I
SOLVING WITH THIRTEEN LADY
UNITED FOR ECONOMIC JUSTICE AND
BANK CHARGES COUPLE CHURCH IN
STRONG SUPPORT. NINE EIGHTY
NINE. DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON
BEHALF OF SAY HOW THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ALLIANCE AND SUPPORT.
TO EXPRESS YOUR SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TOUCH TONE PHONE. LINE ONE
THIRTY NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON
AGAIN TURN MEMBERS NIKITA
KARATE WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. OKAY LET'S GO TO
KERN AUGUSTINE IS GOING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION FROM THE
AUTO ALLIANCE OF AUTOMOTIVE
INNOVATION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- WELL WE DID
IT I HAVE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS
WITH THE AUTO RELATED
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL.
ESPECIALLY IN A THE IMPACT ON
THE ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
MARKET IN CALIFORNIA- WE HAVE
APPRECIATED THE CONVERSATIONS
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO.
THE SPONSORS AND SUPPORTERS OF
THIS BILL. WE ESPECIALLY
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE AND YOUR STAFF AND WE
ARE PREPARED TO CHANGE YOUR
POSITION ONCE. THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED AND WE
HAVE HAD A CHANCE TO REVIEW
THEM WE WILL THEN ADOPT NO
POSITION ON THE- ISSUE OF THE
BILLS BUT AGAIN- BASED ON THE
NATIONAL CONVERSATIONS THAT
WILL THAT OUR INDUSTRY IS
HOLDING WITH PRESIDENT BIDEN
CONGRESS. WE FELT IT WAS
IMPORTANT- TO DELAY THIS OTHER
PORTION OF THE BILL UNTIL
THOSE- ISSUES COULD BE
ADDRESSED AND AVOID THE
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THE STOCK
MARKET IN CALIFORNIA I WILL
CONCLUDE AGAIN ONCE- AGAIN TO
REITERATE MY THANKS TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARILLO- FOR HER
WILLINGNESS TO ENGAGE. WITH US
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ALRIGHT LET'S
NOW GO TO THE PHONE LINES EVEN
ONCE EXPRESSED CONCERNS. ABOUT
THE BILL SEVEN NINETY FOUR. FOR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE EVENT ZERO ONCE AGAIN
THAT'S. ONE SEVEN ZERO. AND WEHAVE A FEW COMMENTS COMING
THROUGH ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE
WE PROVIDE THEM WITH MY NUMBER.
AN ONLINE AT ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTEEN YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
YOU HAVE TO ENSURE MEMBERS
KIRSCH MOTO CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION NEUTRAL ON THE
SWEET PROVISIONS IN THE BILL AS
AMENDED ON MAY TWENTY SEVENTH
AND THANK THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSOR FOR WORKING WITH US.
WHY NO. ONE HUNDRED ELEVEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JUSTIN
OUR PAYMENT WILL COME OUT AND
LEADERSHIP GROUP AND WE HAD IN
OPPOSE POSITION ON THIS BILL
BUT LOOK FOR DIRECT VIEWING THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE DISCUSSED
TODAY. THANK YOU. LINE. ONE
HUNDRED FOURTEEN. SURE MEMBERS
DAN CHAU WITH TESLA. SOME OF
THE COMMENTS OF MR AUGUSTINE-
WE- ARE EAGER TO REVIEW THE
ATTACHMENTS AND ARE PREPARED TO
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION CRESCENTA
WORK OF THE COMMITTEE AND THE
CHAIR OF THE AUTHOR. OF COULD
RESULT IN A TWO THIRDS. ONE ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS
DEAN TALLYWITH THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION JUST LIKE TO LINE
MY COMMENTS WITH MR AUGUSTINE
AND ALSO DAMPENED TESLA
APPRECIATE THE GREAT WORK WITH
THE COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR
AND LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
PRESENT AND THAT'S WHAT THE
DOCTOR THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT LET'S
BRING THE BILL BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS THOUGHTS CENTER
GONZALEZ. YEAH I JUST WANNA SAY
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR AND
THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD INTO SARAH AND THE AND
THE AND THE WHOLE CREW FOR-
BEING THE COALITION THIS IS IN
MY BACKYARD AND SO. FOR ME IT'S
ESPECIALLY- IMPORTANT THAT
WE'RE ALIGNING BOTH LABOR
STANDARDS- AND- OF COURSE
ADVANCING ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
OF FOR THE RESIDENTS THAT LIVE
NEARBY WHICH MANY OF OUR TRUCK
DRIVERS. I JUST WANT TO SEE-
YOU KNOW FAIR STANDARDS FOR
THEMSELVES WHILE ALSO ENSURING
THAT MORE REDUCING GHGS AND
CRITERIA AIR POLLUTANTS SO.
WITHOUT IT- LOVE TO MOVE THE
BILL INAPPROPRIATE AND- I WOULD
LOVE TO CONTINUE TO HEAR MORE
ABOUT THE DISCUSSION AS IT
MOVES FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER- BATES. THANK YOU I
WAS SUPPOSED TO OPPOSE THE BILL
BUT IT SOUNDS TO ME LIKE WE'VE
GOTTEN A GREAT PARTNERSHIP
COMING TOGETHER THAT PROJECTS
KIND OF BOTH SIDES THE AUTO
INDUSTRY AND ALL. OF THE WORK
FORCE I WILL A LAYOFF TODAY AND
HOPES THAT WE'LL SEE THOSE
AMENDMENTS WHEN IT COMES TO THE
NEXT COMMITTEE OR TO THE FLOOR.
BUT THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARILLO AND THAT'S
CERTAINLY THE CO AUTHORS FOR A
HAVING THAT VERY STRONG
ENGAGEMENT ON THE ISSUES THAT
WERE IMPORTANT. TO YOU KNOW
BOTH SIDES THANK YOU. THIRTY
SEVEN DOLLARS. THE RESEARCHER I
HAVE A QUESTION SO IF YOU'RE AN
INDEPENDENT- THE OWNER OPERATOR
AND YOU WANTED TO ACCESS THE
GINGER OF FUNDS I BELIEVE THAT
WILL BE AVAILABLE FOR THIS
PROGRAM WOULD YOU BE REQUIRED
TO BE IN A- THE LABOR AGREEMENT.
NO I MEAN I WON'T SPEAK FOR BUT
IT MAY JUST HAVE TO BE A
PROPERLY CLASSIFIED INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS SO THEY ACTUALLY
HAVE TO. YEAH THE- ON THROUGH
THE CHAIRED BY MAY- THROUGH THE
DEFINITION IS- ON PAGE SEVEN
ACTUALLY IT'S APPLICABLE LAW
VIOLATION- AND WE WORKED WITH
THE TRUCKING ASSOCIATION.
OAKLEY ANYONE WHO IS APPLYING
FOR A CARPSUBSIDY JUST HAS TO
SHOW THAT THEY DON'T HAVE AN
APPLICABLES LAW VIOLATION AND
THAT IS VERY CLEARLY WRITTEN
THAT IT IS AND I'M SATISFIED
UNABATED VIOLATION OF THE LAWS
RELATING TO MISS
CLASSIFICATION. PASS THE TIME
OF APPEAL SO WE TRIED TO MAKE
IT VERY CLEAR AND SO ANYONE WHO
DOESN'T HAVE THAT- WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE SO AN INDEPENDENT
OWNER OPERATOR EVEN IF THEY HAD
ALLEGE MISS CLASSIFICATION
AGAIN SOME WOULDN'T BE THE ONE
WITH THE JUDGMENT AGAINST THEM
IT WOULD BE- THE COMPANY. SAID
THERE WOULD BE NOTHING
PREVENTING THEM IF THEY WERE
TRULY THERE. WELL OBVIOUSLY YOU
KNOW IF THEY WERE IF. THE
FUNDING TO GET IT. RIGHT WILL.
I DON'T KNOW THE PROVISIONS OF
WHATEVER THAT WAS A THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT SEVENTY SAID THREE.
I'LL HAVE TO LOOK AT THAT BUT-
MY CONCERN IS THAT. SOME USE IN
THE CHINESE WE HAVE ALIGNMENT
NOW WITH BASICALLY PERSONAL G.
DRIVE FUNDS COME FROM EVERYBODY
IN THE STATE AND EVERYBODY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO APPLY FOR
THOSE FUNDS WHETHER YOU'RE-
PART OF A BARGAINING UNIT OR
NOT OR YOU'RE PART OF A COMPANY
THAT'S UNION OR NON UNION. AND
SO YOU KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
FOLKS WHO WE'VE SEEN WITH THE
INFINITE CONTRACTING IN AB FIVE
IN ALL THESE RULES THAT COME
THROUGH HERE- BUT SOME PEOPLE
CHOOSE TO DO THAT I JUST WANT
THEM TO BE DISADVANTAGED BY THE
FACT THAT. IF THEY'RE NOT PART
OF- A COALITION OR A COMPANY
THAT. IS APPLYING FOR THOSE
GRANTS THAT THEY STILL HAVE THE
ABILITY TO APPLY FOR THE GRANTS
AND MEET THE CRITERIA. AND WE
KNOW THAT THE TECHNOLOGIES THAT
WERE. BASICALLY FORCING UPON
THEM. AREN'T EVEN REALLY
AVAILABLE YET IN LEAST IN THE-
FULLY HUNDRED PERCENT- NON ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES ON THE LEAST
I TO MY KNOWLEDGE I'VE BEEN
LOOKING I'M IN THE TRUCKING
BUSINESS AND I HAVE NOT SEEN
ANY THAT ARE AVAILABLE YET THAT
MEET THAT CRITERIA AND I KNOW
THIS IS SPECIFIC TO. THE PORTS
AND DRIED STRUCK SO- I'M NOT
GONNA SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY
I WANT I WANT WHAT WHAT WAS IT
SB THREE EIGHTY EIGHT THAT IS
IT IT'S IN THIS BILL AS WELL-
I'M IN. IT BASIC IF YOU ARE A
LEGITIMATE OPERATOR AND HAVE NO
VIOLATIONS OF THE LAW YOU'RE
ELIGIBLE. YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE
UNION MMHM YEAH. AND I JUST I
JUST AS A POINT OF
CLARIFICATION THE MISS
CLASSIFICATION OF POOR DRIVERS
PRE SEEDS AB FIVE BY A LOT THEY
WERE THOUSAND- CASES THAT THE
LATE AT THOUSAND CASES FROM THE
DRIVERS THEMSELVES FILED IN THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE
BEFORE- DYNAMICS OR AB FIVE SO
THIS IS NOT. THAT YOU KNOW AB
FIVE MAKES IT MORE CLEAR FOR A
LOT OF THINGS BUT WE'VE BEEN
DEALING WITH THIS MASK MIS
CLASSIFICATION FOR DECADES.
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY MISS FOR
CLASSIFICATION GIVE ME EXAMPLE
OF WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT
SOMEBODY WHO DOESN'T HAVE A
CLASS ONE LICENSE OR IS THAT
SOMEBODY WHO. ISN'T MISS
CLASSIFICATION AS FAR AS THEIR
STATUS UNDER THE LABOR CODE
THEY'RE THEY'RE TREATED AS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS. OWNER
OPERATOR SOMETIMES AND THE PORT
INDUSTRY IT'S BEEN FOUND OVER
AND OVER AGAIN THEY ACTUALLY
ARE EMPLOYEES OF A COMPANY. AND
AND THE COMPANY IS SKIRTING THE
LAW BY CLASSIFYING THEM AS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS SAVING
THE COMPANY ABOUT THIRTY
PERCENT. TAKING FROM THE
WORKERS THEMSELVES THESE
WORKERS THESE DRIVERS ACTUALLY
FILED SUIT THEY FILED WITH THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE AT
LIKE I SAID THIS IS THIS
PREDATES AB FIVE THIS HAS
NOTHING EVEN. TO DO WITH AB
FIVE BUT UNDER DIE I UNDER
BROWN- PREVIOUSLY- BEEN FOUND
MISCLASSIFIED AND THAT'S
THOUSAND DRIVERS AT THE PORT OF
LA. OKAY THE I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO SAY THAT. I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT YOU CAN BE. WITH THE LAWS
WE HAVE TODAY I DON'T THINK
IT'S REALLY HARD TO BE OUT OF
CLASSIFICATION IF YOU PAY AN
HOURLY WAGE. ARE YOU ACTUALLY
OWN THE TRUCK YOURSELF THERE'S
REALLY. FROM FROM MY
INTERPRETATION OF THE LAWS THAT
HAVE BEEN PASSED. ON AND WE
BROUGHT A TRUCKING BUSINESS SO
WE PAY HOURLY THERE THAT WITH
THE MATTER WHAT IT'S OUR
BECAUSE THERE'S IN YOUR NOSE
WHERE COMPLIANCE I KNOW I'M IN
COMPLIANCE THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO DON'T I COULD TELL
YOU THE STORY I'M SORRY I DON'T
WANNA GET INTO THIS BUT STORIES
OF TRUCK DRIVERS. SHE LOST ME
THEY HAD AT LEAST THEIR TRUCK
FROM THE COMPANY. AND YOU KNOW
THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR
DECADES BUT IT'S NOT YOU ARE
BEING THE JUDGE AND JURY THE
JUDGE HAS ALREADY FOUND THESE
FOLKS OUT OF COMPLIANCE WE JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THEY PAY
THE FACT IS THAT THEY'RE NOT
GETTING. TAXPAYER FUNDS IF
THEY'RE BREAKING THE LAW. HE
BUT I'M GLAD TO PAY HOURLY
THAT'S GOT. THERE'S A BY THE
WAY THERE IS A- A GOOD
DESCRIPTION OF THE ISSUES THAT
ARE DISCUSSED ON PAGE SIXTEEN
AND IT GETS INTO THE- YOU KNOW
THE LARA BILL WHERE THERE'S
THIS LIST OF CARRIERS- THAT
HAVEN'T SATISFIED COURT
JUDGMENTS AND TAX ASSESSMENTS
TAX LIENS SO. THOSE ARE THE
FOLKS WHO ARE IMPLICATED HERE.
OKAY THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
A CENTRE GONZALEZ. WHO IS A
COMING UP REALLY QUICKLY AND I
WANTED TO JUST SPECIFY AND THE
AUTHOR OF SB THREE THIRTY EIGHT
SO IF YOU WANT TO CHAT ABOUT
YOU KNOW. WHAT'S GOING ON IN
OUR BACKYARD AND YOU KNOW MY
BILL ACTUALLY- ARBIL. A BUILD
OFF THE LARA BILL PUTTING
PEOPLE ON THE BAD ACTOR LIST
MULTIPLE OFFENDERS FOR GREGIS.
AGREE JUST VIOLATIONS FROM ITS
CLASSIFICATION THIS IS
SOMETHING NOTED BY STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FEDERAL YOU KNOW.
YOU KNOW THE DEAL SO I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE YOU KNOW THAT
ANY QUESTIONS YOU CAN LET ME
KNOW SO. PART LET'S GO TO THE
REJECTED. AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR HAVOC AND WHAT'S THE PHONE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I NUMBER
THREE EIGHT SEVEN NINE FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBERCARILLO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED RE REFER TO
THECOMMITTEE ON LABOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT ALAN
HI ALAN I BATES. DALLY GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I SKINNER STERN STERN
HIGHWAY CASKEY BY SKI I'VE GOT
FOUR VOTES. OKAY ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH LET'S LIFT
THE CALLS ON WITH WITH THE CALL
ON THE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
FIRST. ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ITEMS ONE SEVEN AND EIGHT STERN.
STERN FIVE SEVEN ZERO OKAY- TO
THAT IS OUT LET'S CLOSE THAT
AND LET'S CLOSE THAT OKAY LET'S
COULD ITEM NUMBER TWO EIGHTY
SIX FIFTY TWO BY FRIEDMAN.
CONSULTAS CHOLERA. I REMEMBER
TO AB SIX FIVE TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED.
CHAIR VOTING I'D VICE CHAIR NOT
VOTING CURRENT VOTE IS THREE
TWO ZERO SKINNER STERN AYE
STERN AYE THAT'S FOUR ZERO ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT
OPEN FOR CENTER SKINNER DOT ON
SHE'S ON HER WAY BELIEVERS AND
CONSUME OKAY GREAT- LET'S GO TO
OKAY WE JUST DID ITEM THREE
THIS TO CREATE A BILL. THAT
WILL KEEP THAT OPEN FOR CENTER
TO SKINNER THAT ON BLOOM BILL
AB TEN SIXTY SIX. ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AB TEN SIXTY SIX ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST B. REFERS THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING I'D VICE CHAIR
VOTING I'D VOTERS FORTY ZERO.
DALLY SKINNER. SKINNER AYE
STERN AYE STERN AYE OKAY WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN AB TEN SIXTY
SIX LET'S TO AB TWELVE HUNDRED
TEN. I REMEMBER FIVE AB TWELVE
HUNDRED BY SOMEBODY MEMBER TANG
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS
AMENDED. VICE CHAIR OF VENTURE
VOTING I'D VICE CHAIR NOT
VOTING SO IT IS THREE TWO ZERO
DALLY. SKINNER HI SKINNER AYE
STERN AYE STERN HI. FIVE ZERO
OKAY WE'RE GONNA CLOSE THE ROLE
ON THAT- ITEM SIX AB TWELVE A
ONE BY TEN. THE ITEM NUMBER SIX
AB TWELVE OH ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TANG THE MOTION
IS DO PASSPORT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTERS
FORTY ZERO SHARE VOTING I'D
VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING DALLY.
SKINNER SKINNER FIVE FIVES TO
ZERO CLOSER ROLE IN THAT NOW
LET'S GO BACK TO AB SIX FIFTY
TWO FRIEDMAN NUMBER TWO. I
DON'T NUMBER TWO EIGHTY SIX
FIFTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN AND THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED SKINNER.
SKINNER FIVE OKAY WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN THAT THAT'S OUT NOW
LET'S GO TO ITEM THREE IS AB
SEVEN NINETY FOUR BY CARILLO
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON LABOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT.
BATES DALLY SKINNER SKINNER I'D
IT'S FIVE TO ZERO OKAY THAT'S A
THAT'S ALL OF OUR VOTES WILL
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND WE WILL
ADJOURN THIS HEARING WILL BE
BACK NEXT WEEK THANK YOU.